Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Jetzt bist du endlich wieder da, du bist so viel unterwegs, musst du eigentlich Roaming-Gebühren bezahlen?
Äh solange ich mich regelmäßig wieder in der Metaebene einlogge, äh habe ich äh freies Roaming.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer hundertfünfundneunzig und nach einer Durststrecke von drei Sendungen.
Was für eine Durststrecke, die waren großartig.
Ah, die Leute vermissen dich doch, Lino.
Kann endlich mal Logbuch loben, weißt du wie gut das tut?
Loben kannst du das? Ja, war gut.
Ja, kann man was sagen, gute Sendung. Ja, kann ich, wenn ich selber dabei bin, dann muss man ja immer so ein so ein.
Muss man sich zurückhalten. Ja, stimmt. Das Understate.
Ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht, das hätte man besser machen können, aber wenn da so anderthalb geil, ey. Internet, Netzpolitik, voll cool, ey.
Ja, ich glaube, es waren jetzt auch ganz,
Ganz äh äh eine ganz schöne Tim äh und und auch Personalbreite, die wir da äh aufgestellt haben.
Gäste für dich ausgewähl.
Ne? Wichser.
Na gut, aber wir haben ja äh wieder genug äh Depressionen zusammengefickt bekommen und da kann man auch mal wieder eine eine Sendung hier äh im alten Style machen,
Von daher haben wir auch ein reich gefülltes Portfolio, äh eine ganze Reihe von äh Terminen
und äh auch noch eine kleine Überraschung für euch und insofern äh.
Eine von den Sendungen, die sollte man zu Ende hören. Am Ende können sie was gewinnen.
An der Fahrung. Aber fangen wir erstmal mit dem langweiligen Kram an.
Ja, das WLAN.
Das W.
Das ewige Thema, die Störerhaftung und äh hier ja nun wirklich auch schon vielfach immer wieder vorgebracht und in den letzten Berichterstattungen hatten wir ja auch darauf hingewiesen, dass da noch so ein
ein Verfahren anhängig ist beim EuGH. Ähm!
Da ging es um den äh Pirat,
Tobias McFedon, der in einem Ladenlokal ein äh offenes WLAN betrieben hat, um Kunden anzulocken, stand in einem der Artikel, die ich dazu gelesen habe, war nicht so.
Zu locken. So ein Lokmodul.
Nee, ist aber, ist aber stimmt ja, ich werde so ein freies WLAN. Ähm ich kenne das ja auch, wenn ich äh im äh im Nicht-EU-Ausland unterwegs bin, äh dann blickt man halt mal ganz kurz äh in wo sind denn hier die Starbucks und die Apple Stores
wo es.
Ja, so ein Lok so ein Lok-Modul Installe, wie bei Pokemon Go irgendwie oder so ein Rauch äh wird verbreitet, den ganzen Pokémons kommen dann so, ah, wie so die Zombies im Nebel. Ah, WLAN, ah.
Mach das WLAN aus, das macht das WLAN aus, das lockt die Nerds an.
Ja, ja, das funktioniert. Der weiß, der weiß Bescheid und äh das hat dann natürlich auch all diese ganzen Netzzombies äh angelockt, die dann ganz schlimme Dinge get,
Die haben dann in Sachen heruntergeladen und so. Ein einziges Lied, auf das sie sich geeinigt haben.
Genau und dann dann wurde er abgemahnt, wie das so ist und jetzt geht es natürlich um die Kernfrage der Störerhaftung, war er jetzt.
Trägt er eine Mitschuld? Äh in diesem Falle, dass äh dass dieses Lied dort äh heruntergeladen und ihr wisst ja, wenn wir von herunterladen reden, dann reden wir die Abmahnung bezieht sich ja nicht auf das Herunterladen,
sondern auf das öffentlich zugänglich machen. Das eben als Teil von äh vom Pointing.
Eben auch geschieht, dass man nicht nur herunterlädt, sondern auch wieder den anderen zugänglich macht und darauf bezieht sich ja dann die,
Abmahnung. Dieses Thema äh wurde vor mehreren Gerichten behandelt, bis es dann irgendwann nach Luxemburg durchgeboxt wurde
und wir wissen, dass der EuGH ja ein Generalanwalt hat, der dann immer so eine rechtliche Einschätzung verfasst und das ist häufig der Fall ist, dass ähm,
der die diese Einschätzung, dass das Gericht dieser Einschätzung,
Folgt. Der Generalanwalt hatte gesagt, dass der dass der äh McFadon, der Betreiber des WLANs zwar gerichtlich dazu verpflichtet werden könne, die von Sony beanstandete Rechtsverletzung zu beenden oder zu verhindern.
Dabei müssten jedoch äh Grundsätze wie die der Verhältnismäßigkeit und der Effektivität beachtet werden. Und das Gericht war nicht vollständig überzeugt und hat entschieden.
Erstens, der Betreiber dieses WLANs ist nicht haftbar. Das heißt, er hat keine Schadenersatzpflicht.
Bedeutet ein entstandenen Schaden kann Sony äh gegenüber
ihm nicht geltend machen. Können jetzt nicht sagen, hier das wurde jetzt zwanzig Mal runtergeladen. Dabei ist uns jeweils folgender Schaden entstanden und das musste jetzt alles bezahlen.
War schon mal ganz gut.
Ja, kommen wir, da kommen wir, kommen wir nachher zu, weil das spielt heutzutage bei Abmahnungen ohnehin kaum noch eine Rolle. Aber zweitens haben sie gesagt,
Sony kann aber Maßnahmen zu Verhinderung weiterer Rechtsverstöße verlangen.
Und solange sie angemessen und verhältnismäßig sind. Und dazu würden zum Beispiel gehören passwortgeschützter Zugang, Registrierung der Nutzer, allerdings nicht eine Überwachung des Netzverkehrs der einzelnen Nutzer.
Und nun wird noch entscheiden sich noch die Geister darüber, ob das Gericht auch entschieden hat, ähm,
Das Unterlassungsansprüche gegen Störer weiterhin zulässig sind. Denn die Idee,
eines Unterlassungsanspruch. Also wenn ein Unterlassungsanspruch besteht,
Ist das die Voraussetzung dafür, dass du überhaupt eine Abmahnung machen kannst? Das Rechtsmittel der Abmahnung haben wir ja,
für den für die quasi schnelle Abhilfe und Abwendung eines Schadens,
Ja, also äh ich glaube, wir hatten hier öfter das Beispiel, du würdest jetzt irgendwas äh Falsches über mich behaupten, in auf einer Internetseite und ich wäre damit unzufrieden, würdest sagen, hier der.
Linus, der hat sie doch nie.
Doof, der ist doof, der hat eine Fünf in Mathe gehabt oder so und dann kann ich abmahnen und sagen, hier ähm,
hör damit auf, bevor ich dich verklage und dann könntest du äh entweder sagen, ne
dann verklag mich. Gut, dann hast du deine Warnung gehabt oder du sagst, ja alles klar, hast recht, hast mich gemahnt. Unseeligerweise kann man eben diese Abmahnung mit einer Kostennote verbinden und da entsteht eben dieses Geschäftsmodell.
Wenn es jetzt keine Unterlassungsansprüche mehr gäbe, gäbe es eben auch keine Grundlage mehr für eine Abmahnung,
Aber da ist eben irgendwie unklar. Also die einen sagen so, die anderen sagen so. Ähm das heißt,
Bordemlein bei einem einmaligen Urheberrechtsverstoß hat der geschädigte Anspruch auf,
auf Verhinderung künftiger Urheberrechtsansprüche kann also sagen macht dieses WLAN zu, damit das nicht nochmal passiert. Ähm,
Er hat aber keine ähm Schadenersatzansprüche.
Jetzt muss man das natürlich noch mit dem neuen äh Störerhaftungsgesetz in Deutschland kombinieren und dann ist es irgendwie äh dann ist das Kuddelmuddel perfekt. Denn was ist letztendlich heißt,
Du haftest zwar nicht. Also das Urteil heißt, du haftest zwar nicht dafür, dass,
wenn andere in deinem dein WLAN nutzen und einen Urheberrechtsverstoß begehen, aber die Geschädigten können dann dich auffordern.
Dein WLAN zuzumachen. Und wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, hieße das, wenn du das dann nicht tust und dann passiert das nochmal, dann bist du sehr wohlhaftbar, weil du würdest ja
darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass wir hier ein, ne, die rechte anderer äh verletzt. Das heißt, es könnte jetzt passieren.
Also was heißt zumachen? Sie sie sagen ja, ein Passwort draufgeben, nur wenn du das als Dienstleistung anbietest, gibst du die Passwörter ja dann auch wieder raus,
Also wo ist der Unterschied? Das ist total gaga. Äh und und hast du dann irgendwas verhindert? Ich meine, wenn du so einen Kaffee, wenn ich mir mal beim Kaffee ein Passwort am am ähm Tresen hole, dann ändert das ja an der ganzen Situation nichts, als wenn gar keins drauf wäre.
Das nationale Recht ähm könnte aber, also, dass ja jetzt hier eine ein EuGH-Urteil, ne, jetzt, dass ein nationale Recht, was dem entspricht, könnte aber zum Beispiel sagen.
Also ist zulässig. Um die Vermeidung zukünftiger Urwehrrechtsverletzungen.
Du zu sichern, musst du das WLAN zumachen und voraus, vor Herausgabe der Passwörter den Personalausweis zeigen lassen.
Also in so einem Café, ne? Ich sitze da ein Milchcafé und
Tages-Flatrate-Internet bitte und dann könnte das nationale Recht zum Beispiel sagen, musst du deinen Ausweis zeigen, damit es hier eine Eingrenzung der der Nutzer gibt. Kann muss aber nicht.
Zeigen und dann nicht nur zeigen, sondern auch noch erfassen und ablegen und Fahrtenbuch führen sozusagen, so ein Internetfahrtenbuch.
Ja, Fahrtenbuch. Fahrtenbuch. WLAN-Fahrten.
WLAN-Fahrenbuch.
Ja ähm kann, kann sein, hast du demnächst. Da musst du auch unterscheiden in private und berufliche Nutzung.
Genau. Haben sie.
Und du musst ein Prozent des WLANs.
War das jetzt privat oder geschäftlich? Nee, nee, ich bin ja im Porn.
Du musst du musst ein Prozent des WLANs äh versteuern jeden Monat. Ähm.
Tja, jetzt wird es natürlich äh ärgerlich. Also wir haben quasi die Störerhaftung tatsächlich
weg, aber auch die freien WLANs und wenn wer sich über mit der Geschichte der Störerhaftung auseinandergesetzt hat,
weiß er, dass wir seit Jahren diesen Aktivismus in dieser Richtung und die das Engagement in dieser Richtung zeigen, gerade um
offene WLANs zu haben, also die Störerhaftung war ja immer, dass der eine Grund, warum wir keine offenen WLANs haben und jetzt haben wir endlich die Störerhaftung weg, aber für den Preis, dass wir keine offenen WLANs mehr haben dürfen,
Oh je.
Ja, das ist echt gar. Also ich verstehe auch überhaupt nicht, wie sie jetzt da auf diese Nummer gekommen sind. Ich verstehe auch überhaupt.
Gibt noch, es gibt noch eine,
gibt noch eine kurze Anmeldung eine kurze Anmerkung, ähm die ich habe im Austausch mit dem Ulf Burmeier mit dem wir hier auch schon zu Gast hatten,
der sagt dieses mit der Perso Pflicht wäre natürlich trotzdem Unsinn denn man weiß ja in sein WLAN oder seinem seinem seinem,
Lokalnetz eben nie, wer hinter der Verletzung stand, denn das sagt das Gericht ja auch, du siehst irgendwie loggen oder sowas, musst du ja nicht, dass äh darfst du sogar nicht, dass das heißt, du,
Dieses Personalausweis zeigen, wenn nur so eine Angstmaßnahme.
Müsstest ja noch die MacAdresse sozusagen zu äh notieren, aber das darf's ja wieder nicht.
Das darfst du wiederum nicht, also ist totaler Quatsch, aber es wäre so dieses es geht hier hinten um diese Angstmaßnahme, ne? Ist irgendwie einer reinkommt und sagt, hier äh WLAN und dann sagst du Zeig Per so und.
Achtzehn.
Ja genau, das.
Das ist wirklich sinnlos, also.
Wichtig ist, der EuGH fordert so eine Pflicht nicht, der sagt nur, dass das Europarecht sowas nicht verbietet, ne? Also diese Verschlüsselungspflicht und so weiter. Ähm.
Und seit am Ende, wie du schon gerade sagtest, totaler Unsinn, ob du jetzt den Zugang offen hast zu diesem WLAN oder nicht, spielt doch überhaupt gar keine Rolle.
Ja, ich war äh am Ende, da das ändert ja nichts daran, was die Nutzer am Ende damit machen. Also Situation, du musst deinen Personalausweis zeigen, du musst
deine Telefonnummer angeben im im Captive Pal und am Ende haben wir,
bekäme dann der Kaffeebetreiber eine Abmahnung, hatte an dem Tag äh sechzig Kunden in der Bude und kann trotzdem nichts machen. Ja, also es führt zu nichts.
Ja und hat vor allem wieder die den denselben administrativen und bedrohlichen Scheißdreck, weswegen er kein WLAN vorher überhaupt.
Eingeschaltet hat, da weil ne? Ich meine die wollen einfach nur den Leuten ein Netz geben, damit sie da ihren in Ruhe ihren Kaffee trinken können und gut ist. Und dann wollen die da nichts mehr mit zu tun haben,
Ja dann.
Es ist eine Katastrophe, es ist eine es ist zum Heulen, ja.
Für sie zum Heulen.
Aber immerhin ähm es gibt äh,
eine Haftungs äh Freistellung äh,
die nicht verboten, also du könntest jetzt im nationalen Recht auch eine vollständige Haftungsfreistellung machen. Das wäre ja der der EuGH hat hier noch schlimmer kommen können, der hätte ja auch sagen können, nö er haftet, fertig,
Dann wäre das Thema noch sehr viel schneller durchgewesen. So haben sie jetzt irgendwie so ein komisches Urteil, um das sich jetzt nationale Gesetzgebung wieder herumwuseln muss.
Ähm dann haben wir auch glaube ich schon eine äh Walldorf-Frommer hat ja dann irgendwie äh also die Abmahnkanzlei Walldorf Rommer.
Es er feiert, dass der EuGH die Störerhaftung bestätigt äh für ungesicherte, anonyme WLAN-Netzwerke und dass sie sich da im Prinzip sehr drüber freuen, ja? Aber die schreiben immer, dass sie sich freuen.
Und ich glaube auch, dass sie sich jeden Tag freuen, wenn.
Solange das alles noch unk.
Viele ihre ihre Gelddruckmaschine an einem Tag auswirft, ne?
Ja. Aber jetzt ist es natürlich nochmal richtig haarig, weil jetzt haben wir natürlich eine EuGH Entscheidung, die jetzt äh quasi
mehr oder weniger eine eine Richtlinie vorgibt für die äh Rechtsprechung und Gesetzgebung in äh allen europäischen Staaten und eigentlich ist nichts klar.
Also jetzt ist es einfach nochmal nochmal extra unklar, weil es jetzt eine zentrale Regelung gibt, die genauso unsinnig ist wie,
Die, die wir vorher hatten, also ich meine, jetzt ist die nationale Gesetzgebung im Prinzip besser als diese europäische Variante, aber man kann jetzt auch irgendwie auch nicht so richtig voranschreiten mit dieser ganzen Argumentation.
Schön wär's gewesen, wenn die die TMG-Reformen, die Unterlassungsansprüche äh abgeschafft hätte. Dann wäre nämlich jetzt Ruhe, dann hättest du vom EuGH die
Haftungsansprüche weg
im nationalen Recht die Unterlassungsansprüche und dann wäre Ruhe, dann könntest du WLAN aufmachen. Aber das wurde ja genau damals auch kritisiert bei der äh TMG-Reform, dass man gesagt hat. Ähm,
Solange diese Unterlassungsansprüche bestehen, haben wir, bleibt der Ärger erhalten und äh genau das ist eben jetzt auch passiert. Tja, also.
Alles Scheiße.
Nicht alles Scheiße, aber wir bauen jetzt mal irgendwann eine vernünftige Rechtssicherheit für WLANs.
Ja, aber ich freue mich jetzt, wo die jetzt herkommen soll.
Schön wäre, wenn der, also wenn der deutsche Gesetzgeber jetzt sagen würde, ähm es gibt keine, also Haftung, gibt's ja dann ohnehin nicht mehr,
und dann sagt es gibt keine Verschlüsselungspflicht und keine Persopflicht fertig, aber wir haben ja da drin stehen geeignete Maßnahmen und so weiter. Das ist es bleibt haarig. Am einfachsten ist das
Leider, ich meine, man wird ja dann auch immer wieder für die äh technischen,
Umgehung äh geschollten, weil sie das Problem nicht lösen, aber mir scheint nach wie vor die einfachste Möglichkeit zu sein, irgendein VPN dahinter zu klemmen, die Sache in in Schweden oder sonst wo rauspurzeln zu lassen oder in dem Freifunk.
VPN und zu sagen, alles klar, jetzt ist wenigstens Ruhe,
Ja, das wäre dann halt wenigstens das klingt für mich nach der Option, wenn man jetzt ein WLAN anbieten möchte. Das ist aber natürlich wieder eine symptomatische Behandlung des Problems und keine ursächliche, ne?
Ja, nur damit tust du natürlich auch Freifunk keinen großen Gefallen, weil die würden das natürlich auch gerne loswerden. Also diese Infrastruktur noch extra dafür aufzurechtzuerhalten ist natürlich auch anstrengend, bringt sie auch äh rechtlich da eine schwierige Situation, weil wir dann halt auch wieder auf einmal ganz anderen Provider
Status wieder hast, den du vielleicht so nicht haben möchtest. Also ist unbefriedigend sowas sagen wir es mal so.
Ja, es ist auch Netzpolitik, da braucht man jetzt nicht nachher zu sagen. Erst wenn wir jetzt ärgerlich.
Wusstet doch womit ihr's zu tun habt.
Wir haben noch was viel, wir haben noch viel schöneres Urteil.
Moppen.
Links, es ist ja so, dass man im Internet, also das Internet, was man im Internet machen kann, ist Link, kennst du Link.
Ja. So eine ganz linke Nummer.
Link ist ja äh Link ist ja im Web, ne. Äh der Verwalt, also das, was den Hypertext irgendwann so das das,
ganze Genie des Hypertechs Hack des Hypertextes liegt hier im Link
dass du wohin klicken kannst und woanders hinkommst. Eine Referenz
herstellst und man dieser folgen kann, ne? Zuvor schrieb man siehe Seite fünf und heute linkt man auf den Enker oder ich glaub das hat man in den Neunzigern gemacht. Ähm, heute macht man ganz einfache kleine Javaske Bibliothek und dann kann man auch woanders hin linken.
Ähm und.
Jetzt stellt sie sich die Frage, was ist denn, wenn ich woanders hinlinke, ja? Was ist, wenn ich auf einen,
illegalen Inhalt Linke bin ich dann daran schuld, mache ich mir den zu eigen. Betrifft natürlich relativ viele, betrifft's, ja also,
ein rechtlich zu beanstandender Inhalt befindet sich im Netz jemand anderes berichtet darüber, was ist jetzt, wenn er darauf linkt oder nicht? Und was rechtlich zu beanstanden heißt natürlich in der Regel
urheberrechtlich zu beanstanden und da sind wir bei dem Fall, den wir.
Oder auch andere Sachen, Verleumderung und so, also es gab ja da verschiedenste Diskussionen, die.
Ja, aber am Ende wird's immer um äh geht's.
Urheberrecht ist natürlich immer.
Immer im Urheberrecht, weil da sind die Leute mit der Kohle. Und da ging es jetzt um das Verfahren von.
GS Media Versusus Sanoma, sehr viel besser bekannt als der Fall Playboy Versus, Rainstyle. Das war dieses äh niederländische äh Magazin.
Die zweitausendelf ein Bericht geschrieben hat, dass äh Playboy-Nackt-Fotos im Internet sein. Ich glaube, das war dann auch sogar vor Veröffentlichung,
heftig, ja? Und haben gesagt, guck mal hier, uh, schau her, was es im Internet gibt, hier sind die Nacktfotos, klicken auf den Link, dann bist du da,
ja? Da wo diese Bilder veröffentlicht wurden, wurde natürlich die Uhr der Urheberrechtsverstoß begangen und der äh der äh,
Eigentümer der Bildrechte oder der Verwertungsrechte, nämlich die Firma Sanoma,
verklagte dann Kane Style, Rainstyle. Erschwerend kam an dieser Stelle hinzu, dass äh,
Sanoma dafür gesorgt hat, dass da wo Train Style hinlinkte, die Bilder auch nicht mehr zu sehen waren. Die haben also eine Take-Downloates gemacht und gesagt, hier Bilder weg. Und was Raine Style dann gemacht hat, ist,
Wir haben woanders hingelingt, weil wie das ja so ist, wenn man im Internet was wegnimmt, dann kommt das ja woanders wieder hoch,
das kennt man auch von früher, dieses Spiel, wo man mit, wo so immer einen Hammer hat und man muss immer auf den Maulwurf draufhauen, ne.
Kennst du, ne? Hast du auch immer gespielt wahrscheinlich früher. Also bevor bevor du ihr Computer hattest.
Wir haben das sogar bei Blink Lights in äh Toronto, kannst du das irgendwie mitm Telefon spielen auf dem Haus.
Ui, ui, ui, ui. Sehr geil.
Na ja weitermal.
Sehr geil. Ja, das haben die auch gespielt und ähm ist dann woanders wieder hochgekommen und jetzt hat auf die andere Stelle gelingt
und gesagt, oh, da ist es weg. Da ist so eine Copyright-Tech-Down Nordis. Ähm jetzt müssen wir woanders hinlinken, weil das was wir, worüber wir hier berichtet haben, ist auf einmal weg und für,
Brauchen eine Quelle dafür. Die Leute lesen den Artikel ja nicht, sondern die wo kommen ja nur zu unserer Seite, um sich von da aus zu den Playboy-Bildern weiterzuklicken,
Und genau das war natürlich dann auch das Problem, denn,
sie hatten dort eine kommerzielle Seite laufen. Und der EuGH hat jetzt entschieden, dass ein höherer Sorgfältigkeitsmaßstab für kommerzielle Betreiber gilt.
Ich zitiere. Im Übrigen kann
wenn Hyperlinks mit Gewinnerzielungsabsicht gesetzt werden, von demjenigen, der sie gesetzt hat, erwartet werden, dass sie erforderlich, dass er die erforderlichen Nachprüfungen vornimmt, um sich zu vergewissern, dass das betroffene Werk auf der Webseite, zu der die Hyperlinks führen, nicht
unbefugt veröffentlicht wurde.
So das zu vermuten ist, dass ein solches Setzen von Hyperlinks in voller Kenntnis der Geschütztheit des Werkes,
und der Edwik fehlenden Erlaubnis der Urheberrechtsinhaber zu seiner Veröffentlichung im Internet vorgenommen wurde. Unter solchen Umständen stellt daher sofern die widerlegte Vermutung nicht entkräftet wird.
Wieder liegliche.
Widerlegliche Vermutungen nicht entkräftet wird. Die Handlung, die im Sätzen des Hyperlinks zu einem unbefugten Internet veröffentlichen Werk besteht
Entscheidender Punkt jetzt, eine
öffentliche Wiedergabe im Sinne von Artikel drei, Absatz eins der Richtlinie zweitausendeins Schriftstich neunundzwanzig da. Der entscheidende Punkt ist hier die öffentliche Wiedergabe, denn das ist ja das, was das Urheberrecht äh betrifft.
Nimmst du eine öffentliche Wiedergabe oder eine öffentliche Zugänglichmachung vor oder nicht.
Also daran ist eben, das ist ja das Urheber oder das ist ja das Urheber- und Verwertungsrecht, was eben auch vorbehalten ist. Wenn du,
Grundsätzlich sagen sie also wenn du nur dahin linkst dann machst du das nicht, machst du die machst nimmst du keine öffentliche Wiedergabe vor wenn du aber jetzt,
dir erkenntlich ist, dass das, was da stattfindet, verboten ist und gegen Rechte verstößt.
Und du dann auch diese Falle machst, wie Creene Style, das äh den Fehler machst, dass sie danach den Link nochmal ändern und quasi durch diese Take-Downloades ihnen klar sein musste,
Dass das, worauf sie der Linken illegal ist.
Dann sagt er, äh, sagt das Gericht, dann hasse es jetzt auch wirklich, dann dann fällt's dir jetzt halt auch unter dieses Urheberrecht. Dummerweise ist das Urteil natürlich nicht so formuliert, dass sie sagen.
Nur wenn man eine.
Zweiten Mal oder wenn du Kenntnis darüber hattest.
Also wenn belegbar ist, dass du es wirklich absichtlich getan hast. Ja. Weil und das wissen wir ja auch. Äh man kann natürlich auf irgendetwas hinlinken.
Wo nix ist und eine Woche später ist da was, weil wer schaut sich schon alle links, die man jemals gesetzt hat an, was dahinter ist? Ich meine, da gehen Domains weg, werden durch irgendwelche Pornanbieter aufgekauft, et cetera, gibt's alles möglich.
Was kümmert mich meine Links von gestern.
Ja und äh es sollten einen auch die Links von gestern eigentlich auch nicht groß kümmern. Und das ist natürlich äh schwierig, ne.
Ja, jetzt, also sie haben ja Leute, dieses ähm diese Einschränkung, sofern die widerlegliche äh,
Vermutung nicht entkräftet wird. Also genau, wenn jetzt das, als ich dahin gelinkt habe, sah das noch anders aus, dann ja. Entscheidend ist weiterhin, was sie hier sagen. Ähm.
Dass es nur für Leute gilt, die Gewinnerzielungsabsicht haben. Ähm.
Und quasi jemand, der keine Gewinnerziehungsabsicht hat.
Der muss eben auch nicht diese Sachen unbedingt prüfen, das heißt diese erhöhte Sorgfaltspflicht machen sie für kommerzielle Anbieter.
Ja gut, Bert. Ja gut, aber dann hast du Problem, ab wann bist du das? Hast du, hast du irgendwie Essenz irgendwie auf deiner Seite, bist du kommerziell Bang.
Und sie gehen davon aus, sagen jemand, der ähm.
Nicht mit Gewinnerziehungsabsicht handelt und vernünftigerweise nicht,
Genau kennen konnte, ob er da ein Urheberrechtsverstoß verlinkt oder nicht, der ist davon freigestellt. Ähm jemand, der eine Gewinnerziehungsabsicht hat.
Bei dem gilt die erhöhte Sorgfaltspflicht und da ist dann als, wird einfach die Kenntnis auch vorausgesetzt. Und,
Spannend ist, dass ihr in einem vorherigen Urteil, ich glaube, dass so ein Jahr her gesagt haben, wenn du ein YouTube-Video bei dir einbettest, ist keine öffentliche Zugänglichmachung. Da haben sie ja quasi wirklich technisch verstanden, ähm dass.
Dieses YouTube-Video woanders herkommt. Du du bettest das ein. Was ja eigentlich der krassere Akt ist als der Link
Ja, also das ist ja dann tatsächlich bei dir äh in gewisser Form zu eigen gemacht, der der Besucher der Seite. Da haben sie gesagt, ähm,
Das ist ähm keine erneute äh öffentliche zugängliche Machung mit dem verlinkten ähm Gleichgesetz.
Also halte ich das eigentlich finde ziemlich gefährliche Entscheid.
Wasser, doppelt doppelt albern ist, weil natürlich auch ein eingebettetes Video, ein Link enthält auf die Seite, also ne also das ist ja im Prinzip da auch nichts anderes. Das ist eigentlich Link Plus.
Der äh Leo
Leonard Dobusch sagt aber bei Netzkritik Ork, dass er es eigentlich schön findet, dass es wenigstens diese Unterscheidung nach Profitabsicht endlich mal gibt, weil das auf Dauer ähm
dafür sorgen könnte, wenn sich das jetzt, wenn das jetzt mal die Runde macht, dass solche Regelungen eben für die Profitabsicht,
Seite der Medaille gelten, dass man mehr Fairys bekommt, dass man quasi sagt, hier der kleine, der kleine Twitterer,
ähm der darf, dem wird sowas nachgesehen, aber wer eine Profitabsicht hat, dem eben nicht,
Äh trotzdem glaube ich, dass das ein bisschen also das klingt alles nicht nach besonders schönen Sachen.
Tschau. Nehmen sie uns nur die Links weg.
Der EuGH lässt uns nicht so gut schlafen.
Lässt nach.
Ja, also schwächelt.
Also als sie als sie noch auf den Generalanwalt gehört haben, waren sie deshalb.
Das ist.
Auf den Trainer, Jungs, hört auf den Trainer.
Ja
Wobei ich nicht genau weiß, was der äh was die Einschätzung des Generalanwalts in dem Fall war. Die haben wir irgendwann hier mal behandelt, aber ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher.
Jetzt ist es, es ist gleich zwölf, wir dürfen drüber reden. Zehn vor zwölf. Es ist zehn vor zwölf, wir brechen die Sperrfrist in einer Aufzeichnung in der Meta-Ebene, um zehn Minuten ähm.
Aber wir veröffentlichen ja nicht.
Wir veröffentlichen dich. Ja, stimmt nicht.
Also nicht vor zwölf. Auch nicht um zwölf, aber.
Jetzt müssen wir noch umpfiffen. Also vor dem Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig ist eine Klage eingegangen,
und diese Klage wurde eingereicht von der Dezix Management GmbH, die Dezex Management GmbH äh gehört dem Eco, wer ist dem Eco untergeordnet, dem,
Verband der oh je, versteht immer eh kein Verwandt, der ähm der Internetwirtschaft ähm,
Klar ECO, ne, macht Sinn.
Und die betreiben den großen europäischen Internet Exchange Dezix. Und wie wir wissen, hat der BND ja an dem DCX äh.
Ähm Überwachungsmaßnahmen durchgeführt und.
Diese Überwachungsmaßnahmen ja mehr oder weniger angeordnet, da ist viel hinter verschlossener Tür passiert, da waren, wo durften sie nicht drüber reden. Der Klaus Landefeld ähm,
Der ich weiß was genau er jetzt ist, wahrscheinlich der Vorsitzende oder Geschäftsführer der Dezex Management GmbH, aber das ist quasi Mister
Dezix hat da auch schon im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss äh drüber gesprochen. Ich denke aber den größeren Teil in nicht öffentlicher Sitzung, wenn ich das jetzt korrekt äh erinnere.
Die haben jetzt gesagt, pass auf, das, was da passiert.
Das wollen wir jetzt mal oft Rechtmäßigkeit prüfen lassen vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht. Wir haben große Zweifel, ob die sogenannte strategische Fernmeldeüberwachung,
Äh nach dem G zehn Gesetz überhaupt rechtens ist.
Vor einigen Wochen haben wir wahrscheinlich auch schon darüber berichtet, dass der,
Herr Papier in einer gut achterlichen Stellungnahme, die Rechtmäßigkeit dieser Anordnungen untersucht hat und in diesem Gutachten zu der zu der.
Zu dem Schluss gekommen ist, dass erhebliche Zweifel bestehen, ob die dort stattfindende Überwachungspraxis überhaupt rechtmäßig ist.
Und genau das wird jetzt in,
Soll jetzt in Leipzig geklärt werden, das ist schon ein ziemlich dickes Ei, was da jetzt passiert. Ähm,
Unter Umständen steht auch der äh Weg nach Karlsruhe offen. Ich würde eigentlich vermuten, dass der früher später auch äh beschritten werden wird, weil es ja hier dann am Ende auch um diese um,
Artikel zehn Grundgesetz geht um die Einschränkung des Artikels zehn im ähm äh im,
Artikel zehn gesetzt und eben dann um die Ausformulier ausformulierung dessen, was das ähm,
Was der BND aus diesem Gesetz gemacht hat. Ja, also ich denke, dass äh im Bundesverwaltungsgericht wird jetzt erstmal formal geprüft werden, ob man diesem Gesetz entspricht und wenn man da nicht wirklich vernünftig weiterkommt, äh dann wird das Ganze eben unter Umständen sogar noch
nach Karlsruhe gehen. Das heißt, dass jetzt gerade der Betreiber des größten Internetexchanges in Deutschland und ich glaube, des größten in Europa,
Den BND verklagt hat. Das ist schon das ist dick,
Das ist ein ordentliches Ei. Das ist eine, da werden wir jetzt mal sehen, was daraus wird.
Die Klage ist jetzt erstmal am Bundesverwaltungsgericht. Das klingt ja so, als ob sich das noch ein bisschen äh hocheskalieren äh kann und wahrscheinlich auch wird.
Genau, kannst, wird sich im Zweifels, also ich halte es für sehr wahrscheinlich, dass ich das hoch äh dass das weitereskaliert nach Karlsruhe.
Dann kommt natürlich in diesem Verfahren kommen noch ganz andere spannende Aspekte rein, nämlich natürlich ist ja hier,
ihr findet ja eine Klage statt über Zucker geheim zu haltende Sachverhalte. Das heißt diese Klageschrift kann eigentlich in ihren Details.
Nicht wirklich veröffentlicht werden. Und auch die Verhandlung.
Für die Verhandlungen werden sich, wird sich die Frage stellen, kann die öffentlich stattfinden oder eben nicht? Ja, weil hier wird ja was, ne, wir haben ja diese.
Ist ja geheim.
Genau das Gleiche wie mit diesem Gagorders gegen die sich Nick Marrel vor Jahren gewährt hat. Es könnte es steht ja theoretisch die Möglichkeit im Raum, dass das alles legal ist und eben geheim
Und dass es eben aber auch geheim bleiben muss. Also wie das wie das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in diesem Rahmen jetzt ein Verfahren äh führen möchte,
Verhandlungen führen möchte, ein ein Urteil sprechen möchte, ähm stellt da die Gelehrten noch einmal vor eine sehr spannende
Herausforderung. Deswegen wahrscheinlich auch die relativ lange Wartezeit. Ich meine die Position von Klaus Landefeld in diesem Bereich
war schon klar, dass er äh auf diese Snowden-Sache kein Bock hat, dass er auf diese BND-Sache keinen Bock hat. Wir haben immer wieder gesehen, dass äh der Dezix da,
In dem Rahmen dessen, wie er sprechen konnte, ähm,
immer anfangs gesagt hat, dürfen wir nicht drüber sprechen, sich dann zurückgezogen hat, wahrscheinlich in Klausurtagung mit den Anwälten gegangen ist und geguckt hat, was können wir irgendwie machen. Und äh jetzt schließe ich an den Punkt gekommen sind, okay, wir wir werden diesen,
Rechtsweg bestreiten, um,
unsere Kunden zu schützen, ja? Also was passiert hier? Wir wir verkaufen den Leuten diese Ports, wir dipieren bei uns, wir verdienen damit Geld.
Liefern sie das Messer.
Und liefern sie da einer unter Umständen nicht rechtlichen äh Massenüberwachung aus,
Informieren unsere Kunden nicht darüber, die können wiederum ihre Kunden nicht darüber informieren, der BND, was der damit macht, ist sowieso völlig unklar. Und dann stellt sich natürlich die Frage der DDX ist natürlich mitnichten ein
ein ein deutscher Internet-Exchange. Internet kennt ja wenig,
Wenig Nation und ähm da stellt natürlich die die Frage, die sich ultimativ stellt.
Der ist grundgerecht, das Grundrecht aus Artikel zehn, ist das jetzt auf das Territorium der Bundesrepublik Deutschland begrenzt,
oder nicht. Und wenn das nicht auf das äh auf das Territorium der Bundesrepublik Deutschland äh begrenzt ist, wie kann dann der BND dort
den internationalen Traffic abhören, denn wir wissen ja, der BND darf ja gar nicht deutschen Traffic abhören, das heißt, der BND sitzt in Deutschland.
Und versucht internationalen Traffic abzuhören, unterliegt aber dem Grundgesetz und dem Artikel zehn Gesetz.
Weil er in Deutschland, weil es in Deutschland stattfindet, aber eigentlich ja nicht, weil es der BND ist. Also wird jetzt da werden dann natürlich da wird noch die eine oder andere Welttraumtheorie entfaltet werden.
Ich glaube auch, dass Bundesverwaltungsgericht wird es sehr zügig nach oben durchreichen, weil mit dem Kram wollen sie bestimmt nichts zu tun haben. Na ja. Also das wird. Hier nimm.
Eine heiße Kartoffel, ja. Also, dass wir das aber erstmal wirklich Wut ab, dass äh dass hier ein Internet ist Change-Betreiber eben sagt, bäh! So nicht.
Ja, ich meine sich mit dem Support von Hans-Jürgen Papier da an der Stelle äh ausgestattet zu sehen, das hat sicherlich die den Schritt beflügelt. Das ist ja nun auch nicht irgendjemand, sondern jemand, der sich halt in den letzten Jahren eben auch äh
extrem natürlich damit auseinandergesetzt hat, natürlich auch selber Präsident des Bundesverfassungsgerichts war und von daher natürlich auch.
Man ihm jetzt nicht unbedingt äh unterstellen kann. Er hätte jetzt von dieser Materie keine Ahnung,
So. Also äh das ist schon äh wirklich sehr interessant. Mich faszinieren überhaupt die diese ganzen,
nicht alle, aber die, die ich bisher so wahrgenommen habe, die Mitglieder des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, die haben schon wirklich einen einen Doktor und dann äh sind auch auf eine Art und Weise staatstragend, die finde ich schon äh bemerkenswert,
Ja, also diese Klage geht jetzt raus. Die Zix verklagt den BND,
dicke Nummer, müssen wir mal gucken, wird heute sicherlich auch äh nicht nur Wallock Buchnetzpolitik ganz gut durch die Posthillen zirkeln und wir äh werden das begleiten, was hier passiert, aber stellt euch nicht auf schnelle Ergebnisse ein,
Aber ist natürlich äh auf jeden Fall für den BND der nächste äh PR-Gau gleich nachdem äh das A Untersuchungsausschuss könnte dazu führen, dass es dann wieder neue Gesetze gibt und ihnen noch mehr Rechte.
Ja, genau, das ist das einzige, was wir gerade Sorgen machen. Das ist das Einzige, was mir gera.
Mehr Geld. Ach, das war auch illegal. Na ja, da müssen wir da auch nochmal irgen.
Deswegen hoffe ich, dass die nach äh dass sie schön fleißig nach Karlsruhe gehen. Ähm tja.
Dann haben wir ja so einen europäischen digitalen Binnenmarkt, der mal ein bisschen harmonitarisiert werden muss.
Und da haben wir auch direkt den richtigen Mann dafür, nämlich den äh die Digitalkommissar Güter, Günther Oettinger.
Der hat jetzt ein äh großes Programm vorgestellt zusammen mit dem ah der Name ist sogar, wie heißt der Andros Ansippner? Ähm,
Die haben gesagt, ja, wir wollen
Wir haben jetzt hier die Vorschläge der EU Kommission für eine Modernisierung des Urheberrechts und der Titel, der Telekommunikationsmarktregeln und was nicht alles hier muss alles harmonetarisiert werden. Ich glaube, insgesamt ein äh sechzehn,
Initiativen planen erstmal jetzt nur vorgestellt mit so,
Mit viel äh Hameltarisierungssprech äh der E-Commerce über die Grenzen muss einfacher werden. Die Verbraucherschutzregeln müssen konsistent in der EU äh,
durchgesetzt werden können. Man möchte eine schnellere und einfacher äh oder schnellere und günstigere Zustellung von,
von Paketen haben, damit man irgendwie.
Im also innerhalb Europas eben auch einfachere Shipping hat, ja. Äh sonst das ist ja auch ein Hindernis des freien Marktes, wenn du auf einmal aus äh Rumänien was nach Deutschland schicken musst und höre
Paketkosten hast, als wenn du die Ostdeutschland direkt schickst, ja? Dann wollen sie dem Geoblocking ein Ende bereiten, solange es
Unjustice ist,
Insgesamt ist es ja immer ein großer Fan des Geo-Blockings. Dann wollen sie natürlich irgendwelche äh Kartellrechte äh stärken, völliger Unsinn. Ich meine,
dieses eine Harmonisierung und Liberalisierung eines Binnenmarktes ist ja das Erstellen von größeren Kartellen,
Also wenn du Kartellrecht anwenden möchtest, dann suchst du es auch so dafür, dass es viele unterschiedliche Regeln gibt, damit die Monopole wenigstens in einzelnen Ländern sich sind, er möchte natürlich aber okay, lassen wir das. Lassen wir das, in solche Gespräche braucht man sich ja gar nicht mit Günther Oettinger einzulassen.
Modernes europäischeres,
Copyright wollen sie haben, ja? Man hört hier den Trump-Speak, ne? Das ist äh man möchte, dass es Anamerican, das European, Coffee Right ist nicht, ist.
Make Copyright Greatigan.
Nee, Copyright, äh, European Agent, ja? Ähm dann wollen sie irgendwie sich mit,
Satellites und Cable, Directivs auseinandersetzen. Telekommärkte, äh, regulieren, audiovisuelles Medien-Framework für das einundzwanzigste Jahrhundert haben, dann bist du irgendwann nur noch bei irgendwelchen Buzzwords ähm,
Aber dann kommen natürlich auch wieder die Klassiker, Online-Plattformen müssen sie sich Wege finden, wie sie am besten illegale Inhalte äh aus dem Internet verschwinden lassen können,
Äh Sicherheit muss natürlich auch erzwungen werden mit der E-Privacy Directive und äh Datenschutz und Cyber-Security brauchen sie natürlich auch und ähm
Der freie Flow der Daten in die europäische Cloud
Standards für die Interoperabilität brauchen wir uns Skills und E-Government. Und äh dann musste man irgendwie mal lange hinhören und gucken, was sie überhaupt alles vorhaben,
Und dann stellt sich raus, ja zum Beispiel zu so diesen europäischeren Urheberrecht, was jetzt hier angestrebt wird, gehört natürlich dann erstmal der die Erfolgsgeschichte des Leistungsschutzrechtes für,
Presseverlage. Kommerzielle Internetanbieter wie Google News sollen dann für die Verbreitung auch von Anreißern und Kleinstausschnitten an Artikeln,
An deren Urheberzahlen und die Rechte soll bis zu zwanzig Jahre lang durchgesetzt werden können.
Macht.
Und dann wurde natürlich Oettinger gefragt so, ja ähm wir hatten bisher nicht den Eindruck, dass das mit dem äh,
Mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverleger so eine gute Idee ist, weil wir haben ja gesehen, wie in, ich glaube war das Spanien und Belgien,
wo Google News dann einfach abgeschaltet wurde und wir haben gesehen in Deutschland, dass alle großen Anbieter innerhalb kürzester Zeit sofort die Ausschlüsse hatten
quasi die Ansprüche vollständig abgetreten haben gegenüber Google News.
War ja nun mal von Google News der Traffic kam und als Google News gesagt hat, ja gut muss nicht,
kein Problem, wenn ihr den Fendy und in Traffic nicht haben wollt, das war ein Angebot
wenn ihr jetzt hier die Hyperlinks verbietet und und dann ist auch okay, dann machen wir das halt nicht mehr, dann sind sie rumgerannt, haben oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, komm.
Haben wir es ja nicht gemein.
Keiner mehr auf unsere Seiten. Jetzt müssen wir die zwingen wegen ähm wegen Marktmacht, weil die lassen uns jetzt hier in der Wüste veröden,
Und dann sagte Ötzinger, na ja, äh eine Online-Plattform, ein OT wie Google
Over the Top Service wie Google ist bereit auf einen Teilmarkt Spanien zu verzichten. Aber der europäische Binnenmarkt mit fünfhundertzehn Millionen Menschen ist für jeden globalen Player so wichtig, dass er
auf ihn nicht verzichten wird. Mit anderen Worten, sie sagen halt so, ja äh,
Du legst dich vielleicht mit Spanien, mit Belgien an, du erpresst vielleicht die Deutschen, aber wenn wir, wenn wir hier mal als Europäer an einem an einem Seil ziehen, dann können wir Google vielleicht doch erpressen. Ich glaube, er denkt da so an China, ne, wo Google dann irgendwann auch relativ viele
Kompromisse eingegangen ist, weil sie unbedingt natürlich nicht auf diesen chinesischen Markt äh verzichten wollen. Äh sowas scheint hier,
dem äh Zentraleuropäischen Zentralkomitee für digitalen Binnenmarkt äh vorzuschweben.
Ich habe äh ich habe nur wenig Verständnis.
Dieser dieser dieser Öttinger muss da wirklich ganz schnell deinstalliert werden. Das ist einfach wirklich ein Drama. Es wäre langsam mal wirklich mal Zeit, jemanden zu haben, der das irgendwie auch versteht von äh äh die Rehe ist.
Der Mann stellt ähm.
Stellt irgendwie diese Kriterien für die für die IT da vor und brüstet sich irgendwie, ich glaube in der gleichen Woche damit, dass er keine E-Mail hat, ne.
Ja, da gab's irgendwie so eine ja hat keine private E-Mail-Adresse, habt ihr eine ja natürlich im Fokusinterview.
Hat er nicht. Man muss auch mal abschalten können, das mit dem Internet, das auch alles so ein bisschen äh ne.
Setze ich auch nicht durch.
Ja, das setzt wird sie nicht durchsetzen, das regulieren wir jetzt in Ruhe kaputt, dafür bin ich ja da.
Hauptsache ich habe meine Sonntagszeitung auf dem Frühstückstisch.
Das ist der hat keine keine private E-Mail ab Adressen.
Gut, kannst dir natürlich vorstellen, er hat dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie eine eine berufliche E-Mail-Adresse, wo dann eine Angestellte Person äh für ihn die E-Mails ausdruckt und dann kann er äh eine Antwort diktieren oder sowas.
Dieses Interview ist eh wieder äh wirklich schön, ne? Ich meine, man muss ja sehen, der Öttinger hat ja gerade eine.
Aber das wird keine.
Der hat eine riesige Niederlage gerade einkassiert mit was die Netzneutralität angeht, ne?
Das musst du mal überlegen. Der Mann hat gerade richtig versagt. Was der auf Netzneutralität geflucht. Wir erinnern uns. Das haben wir, glaube ich, auch mal den einen Spieler gehabt, ne? Mit der, der Bengel spielt hinten im Internet und das Auto und Tier und.
Operation geht schief, weil der Bänge da hinten.
Ja genau, der Bengel spielt, der Bengel spielt YouTube und die Operation apportiert das falsche Bein oder so ein Beispiel war das irgendwie eine Wahl, die Pakete falsch rum und in letzter Tag,
dann wird der natürlich im Fokus mit dieser Frage konfrontiert und antwortet. Wir haben immer gesagt, dass wir Netzneutralität wollen.
Wir haben dieses äh Prinzip auch erstmals im EU-Gesetzestext verankert. Die Internetgemeinde ist jetzt zufrieden, dass die konkreten Vorgaben für die Umsetzung auch dem äh entspricht. Und ihre ursprünglichen Bedenken nun ausgeräumt sind. Das kann ich nur begrüßen.
Ja, das ist einfach also Netzneutralität ist für uns eine sehr konkrete Geschichte,
In dem politischen Prozess ist es ein Gummiwort.
Was mit was auch immer gefüllt wird, was was in dem Moment gerade in die aktuelle Debatte äh reinpasst. Das ist auch das Problem dieses Begriffs, der halt auch viele andere Begriffe.
Der ja von sich aus heraus nicht jedem sofort klar macht, worum es geht. Man, ne, Hass, hast du auch immer Störerhaftung, finde ich dann zum Beispiel schon mal,
deutlich konkreter.
Gewisser Hinsicht so. Aber Netzneutralität, das kann alles sein. Neutral auf welcher Ebene, wem gegenüber, zu welchem Zeitpunkt, also ne, wir hatten wir äh haben da eine sehr konkrete Vorstellung und haben die ja nun auch äh immerhin durchgesetzt bekommen
aber das ist natürlich,
Kann man jetzt nicht erwarten, dass das jetzt jeder Player ähm dieselbe äh Definitionsleiste da äh an die man schraubt, die wieder eben haben.
Aber was der gemacht hat, war schon ganz. Also ich finde das, weißt du, du kannst nicht einen europäischen Digitalkommissar äh damit äh entschuldigen, dass Netzneutralität ein Gummiwort ist. Der wusste ganz genau, worum's da geht,
Deswegen hat er ja auch diese äh diese lächerlichen Beispiele da genutzt und so. Und der hat eben hier in diesem Fall verloren.
Analog Single Market.
Achtet.
Ja
Eines Tages werden wir uns ihn noch herbeisehen. Ja, aber er hat irgendwie äh auf jeden Fall Stäuber äh komplett überholt, was so so seine verstörte äh Öffentlichkeitskommunikationswahrnehmung angeht.
Ne
Ja
Stolper redet keiner mehr.
Ja gut, der ist aber jetzt so netzpolitisch nicht äh ja.
Ja, Gott sei Dank. Stell dir mal vor, das Datenpaket muss muss direkt direkt an den Server ran. In zehn Minuten.
Zehn Minuten vom Hauptbahnhof in München.
Kommt man da sofort hin.
So, dann haben wir noch eine schöne Meldung aus der unendlichen Geschichte. Ähm der Landesverrat um im und um und um Netzpolitik Ork herum,
Und zwar gab es im August zwanzig fünfzehn eine Sondersitzung des Rechtsausschusses im Deutschen Bundes,
Tag. Die haben sich da mit der Landesverratsaffäre auseinandergesetzt und dieses Protokoll war nicht öffentlich. Da gab's also ging es,
Unter anderem insbesondere um den Zank zwischen Justizminister Maas und,
Generalbundesanwalt Harald Range und wer da jetzt wen angewiesen hat und so weiter. Der Mars hat jetzt im in vergangener Zeit nochmal auf dieses,
Protokoll Bezug genommen. Ähm,
gesagt, hier das steht ja schon da in diesem Protokoll drin, dieses Protokoll betrifft eben den neunzehnten August zweitausendfünfzehn, ist also über ein Jahr her und
da hat er aber in einer weiteren Anhörung jetzt irgendwie, ich glaube, am dreiundzwanzigsten neunten wurde darauf Bezug genommen,
Und jetzt dann haben Netzpolitik Ork gesagt, na das wäre doch äh verrate doch mal. Verrate doch mal. Kannst du uns bitte dieses Protokoll schicken? Haben das beim Justizministerium angefragt.
Und das Justizministerium hat ihnen das geschickt. Ähm
Und äh Netzpolitik Ork hat es dann äh veröffentlicht am am vierundzwanzigsten August zwanzig sechzehn. Er hat gesagt, hier ist das öffentliche äh Protokoll, nicht öffentliche Protokollprotokoll dieser Sondersitzung, ja? Und äh dann
das war eine relativ,
Angelegenheit, weil dieses Protokoll äh wurde ja verfasst und als nicht öffentlich eingestuft vom Rechtsausschuss des Deutschen Bundestages.
Das Justizministerium,
Die exekutive dieses Protokoll hatte war ja nur, weil äh du als Teilnehmer einer solchen Anhörung das bekommst. Und jetzt hat natürlich der ähm Maß die,
Den Rechtsausschuss und den Bund deutschen Bundestag brüskiert, dadurch, dass er dieses nicht öffentliche Protokoll veröffentlicht hat. Ähm also quasi eine ähm.
Die Hoheit äh dieses Verfassungsorganes verletzt hat über die Bestimmung. Ob das jetzt öffentlich ist oder nicht öffentlich diese.
Ein Abgrund von Landesverrat.
Es ist ein Upgrade von Landesverrat und dann macht das natürlich noch ein besonders amüsanten Eindruck, dass er das dann auskennt und auch an Netzpolitik or.
Ist geil. Jetzt sind wir noch Quitt, oder?
Ähm,
Das hat also äh für kurzzeitigen Tumult gesorgt. Ähm das Justizministerium hat sich dann
entschuldigt, äh die eine Sprecherin sagte oder in der Süddeutschen Zeitung, es sei ein Versehen gewesen, sie war nicht ganz klar, dass das Ding nicht öffentlich ist, aber ähm man
wäre sich vor allem gegen diesen Vorwurf der Kumpanei zwischen Netzpolitik Org und.
Und dem Justizministerium, denn auch ein anderer Journalist hätte angefragt und auch dem hätte man dieses Protokoll gegeben.
Ja. Sehr schön.
Aber ist natürlich irgendwie äh ungelenk. Ähm es gibt dann auch einen ähm Kommentar von.
Landesfahrrad kann man sich eigentlich auch mit hups äh sorry herausreden sozusagen.
Na ja, das ist ja jetzt nicht unbedingt Landesverrat. Das ist ein nicht öffentliches Protokoll. Äh okay. Äh einen Tagesspiegel gab es dann, wie gesagt, diese Kumpelte, das Justizministerium mit mit Netzpolitik und Markus hat da natürlich auch nochmal dazu geschrieben ähm,
Wir haben hier äh das Dokument angefragt und öffentlich gemacht, äh das äh,
Ist natürlich äh dieser Vorwurf der Kogelais hier einfach nicht, ja. Nicht zulässig.
Na ja, aber äh amüsant ist es trotzdem wie äh was für.
Find's natürlich auch bezeichnend, dass jetzt ausgerechnet Heiko Maas in dieser ganzen Geschichte ähm derzeit eigentlich am meisten auf den Deckel bekommt.
Ja, das äh also das wird ja auch immer wieder gerade auch vom Markus, also,
Die Hauptverantwortlichen für die Ermittlungen gegen uns Hans-Georg Maaßen und den nachdem Kret kein Hahn mehr, ja? Auch das Innenministerium, was das Wissen von hatte und das geduldet hat, äh die kriegen auch keinen mehr auf den Sack.
Und jetzt kriegt ihr irgendwie, jetzt hauen sie die ganze Zeit auf den Maßen ein.
Auf dem Maß. Auf den Maßhorn.
Den Mars, ja, auf den Mars ein.
Der halt zumindest, ich meine, man kann jetzt über seine Motivation sicherlich auch nochmal geteilter Meinung sein, aber er hat für mein Empfinden ein eine Strategie gefahren, die doch stark deeskalierend äh wirkt.
Wie wir damals noch berichtet haben, äh Korrektiv hatte er schon darüber berichtet, dass äh Bundesangelegen äh Bundesanglach Kanzlerin Merkel.
Bundesangela.
Die Bundesangeler äh,
quasi dem Maß eine Rückendeckung dafür gegeben hat, diese Ermittlungen zu stoppen und darüber hatte sich der äh ehemalige BND-Präsident August Hanning sehr äh beklagt.
Wo kommen wir denn dahin.
Ne. Na ja, aber ganz amüsanter. Einige amüsanter Zwischenfall.
Ein nicht ganz so amüsanter Zwischenfall war der mehrtägige Hungerstreik von Chelsea Melling.
Hat ja erst,
Wie wir uns erinnern, vor kurzem ein äh Suizidversuch äh unternommen und äh ist jetzt in Hungerstreik getreten.
Weil ihr die Geschlechtsumwandlung oder das Treatment ihrer äh,
Ich glaube der US-Begriff ist äh Genderdisforia, also quasi das, ne, das äh,
Der körperliche Marke, dass dein Geschlecht nicht zu dem gefühlten gehört,
genau, das soll, dass du im falschen Körper bist und man den ja glücklicherweise umbauen kann, auf das du dann dich besser fühlst. Mit deinem Körper,
Da hatte das äh Justizminister äh das Verteidigungsministerium im Juli erst angekündigt, dass sie äh Transgenderpersonen zum Dienst zulassen und äh falls nötig auch die medizinischen Behandlungskosten übernehmen
Aber es war weiterhin unklar, ob das eben auch für Häftlinge in Militärgefängnissen gilt.
Und ähm da hat äh Jelsey Melling jetzt mit einem mehrtägigen Hungerstreik eben die Zusage.
Ähm erreicht, dass ihr diese adäquate Behandlung ähm nicht mehr verweigert wird.
Mit anderen Worten ist es abzusehen, dass es vielleicht auch stattfindet.
Ja, also das wurde jetzt zugesagt, ne. Äh denn ursprünglich hatte sich die US-Armee geweigert, äh ihr im Zuge dieser äh Geschlechtsumhandlungen Hilfe zukommen zu lassen.
Und äh das hat sie jetzt eben offenbar auf diesen Missstand hat sie aufmerksam gemacht und äh.
Eine Zusicherung bekommen, die ausreicht, dass sie diesen äh Hungerstreik beendet hat.
Das ist schon äh nach wie vor äh wie gesagt eine eine Schande. Und ähm ich habe das ja.
Schon vor einigen Sendungen angesprochen. Ich habe das auch ja im Namen des CC da eine Pressemitteilung äh,
veröffentlicht und verfasst,
Dass eine Begnadigung dieser Person jetzt durchaus mal langsam angemessen werde und äh wie ich's ja auch schon habe, durchklingen lassen, ist jetzt die American Civillimittes Union äh mit einer Kampagne an den Start gegangen, Snowden,
zu begnadigen. Ähm ich finde das äh bedauerlich, dass da äh Chelsea Mening nicht mit nicht in gleicher.
Gleichem Ausmaß mit äh in dieser Kampagne, ja? Da kann man ja.
Marias Noten, in dem Sinne auch noch gar nicht verurteilt ist für irgendetwas oder noch nicht mal ein Haftsitz, sondern ja eigentlich nur gesucht.
Und da haben wir diese arme Person, die irgendwie suizid versucht, Hungerstreik in der im Militärgefängnis äh abfeiert.
Abfeiern.
Und das ist äh nach wie vor wirklich eine große Schande.
Also wenn ihr was wenn ihr irgendwie was Gutes tun wollt, unterstützt die, unterstützt die das Leben und den Kampf von Chelsea Mening.
Auf allem anderen ist gerade genug Aufmerksamkeit. Nicht auf allem anderen, aber vielen anderen ist gerade mehr Aufmerksamkeit.
Ein bisschen zu wenig.
Unsere Aufmerksamkeit liegt vor allem bei der EU denn wir haben am laufenden Meter EU-Themen hier.
Ja
Hätten wir, hätten wir auch besser sortieren können, finde ich.
Ja, die Themen habe ich diesmal nicht so gut sortiert, aber das ist doch auch in Ordnung, dann hat man mal so ein bisschen, die Leute waren ja auch immer noch, was kommt am Ende? Was können wir gewinnen?
Was könnte es sein?
Wir haben, also ich kann ja in kurz äh ich kann ja einen kurzen äh Spoiler geben, wenn man so einen kleinen Hinweis. Wir haben eine sehr interessante E-Mail bekommen von einem nigerianischen Prinzen.
Und ähm da äh da haben wir also echt eine Idee hier, wenn wir Glück haben.
Nein.
Wir sind noch im seriösen Teil.
Sind noch im seriösen Teil. Nein, wir sind im völlig unseriösen äh Teil des Podcasts, denn äh es gab mal wieder ein wir erinnern uns an das Versprechen der EU-Kommission zweitausendfünfzehn, wo gesagt wurde, ab dem Sommer zwanzig siebzehn gibt es.
Kein,
Roaming-Gebühren, EU-Ausland mehr. Gibt's nicht mehr? Frei, freies, freies Roaming für freie Bürger in einem freien, digitalen Binnenmarkt,
Sache.
In einem Vereinigten Europa.
Im Vereinigten Europa freies Roaming für freie Mobilfunknetze und an der Grenze Datenpaket. Netzneutral rüber und so weiter. Aber dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, wenn sie das machen würden.
Und das freie Roaming unbegrenzt gilt, dann würden sie ja äh den europäischen,
Mobilfunkmarkt harmonisieren und dann könnte das ja sein, dass sich jemand mal eben eine Prepaid-Karte in Land A holt und der dann im Inland B,
in Genuss denn der günstigeren Konditionen kommt, die dies in Land A gibt,
Und dann ja könnte es ja sein, dass du dir dann eben billige, was weiß ich, SIM-Karten aus Frankreich, aus Holland oder sonst wo holst und damit im deutschen Netz oder im einem anderen Netz,
bessere Koalition genießt, als die Lokalangeboten werden. Und irgendjemand wird ihnen gesagt haben, hör mal, äh.
Das wäre ja ein digitaler äh Single-Market, also.
Das wäre ja ein ein harmonetarisierter Markt und dann äh dann stürzte ja allerlei
Nationalstaaten in Ungemach, wenn die auf einmal keine Kunden mehr haben, weil die alle abwandern, ja? Also die Menschen wandern quasi, sage ich mal von den Einländern der EU in die anderen und die Mobilfunkverträge in genau in die andere Richtung, das wollen wir ja nicht,
Das wollen wir nicht. Das kann nicht sein.
Versaust du dem Schäuble die schwarze Null.
Damit versaust du eine ganze Menge. Da brauchen wir verbrauchen, pass auf, ein sonst gar nicht so beliebter Begriff, aber was wir da bräuchten, wäre Fairys. Und Fair-Use haben sie sich überlegt, Fairyus machen wir so, da haben sie jetzt den Entwurf vorgestellt,
Du kommst in den Genuss dieses keine Roaming-Gebühren im EU-Ausland insgesamt neunzig Tage pro Jahr und maximal neunzig Tage, äh dreißig Tage am Stück.
Und wenn du jetzt sagen wir mal für ein drei für einen viermonatigen Aufenthalt in äh
die Niederlande gehst mit deinem Vertrag, dann müsstest du einmal alle dreißig Tage dich im deutschen Heimatnetz wieder einbuchen.
Und nach Ablauf der drei Monate und neunzig Tage im vierten Monat hättest du kein freies Roaming mehr.
Also so ein bisschen weniger. Also es es wendet sich sozusagen an den an den Urlauber, ne? So an den. Man ist mal.
Für den Urlauber ist das okay, aber wenn du so, ne, wenn du dann mal länger bleibst, dann bitteschön nicht. Ähm,
Zusätzlich wollen sie den Verkauf von Prepaid-Simkarten beschränken, damit die Betreiber des ausländischen Netzes,
Quasi, die kriegen halt quasi das Recht zu verlangen, dass erst eine gewisse Menge an Daten im Heimatnetz verbraucht wurde, bevor das kostenlose Roaming freigeschaltet wird,
Ja, also auch um da zu, weil sie ja natürlich verstanden haben ähm dass wenn du dieses Robing-Problem hast,
dass äh und dann die neunzig Tage oben sind, dann holst dir einfach die nächste Prepaid-Sam.
Und hier wird dann eben verlangt, bevor du diese Prepaids im im Ausland dann nutzen kannst, muss die irgendwie ein bisschen angebraucht sein.
Es wird natürlich jetzt viel als äh zurückrudern äh bezeichnet und so, aber man muss natürlich auch andererseits anerkennen, dass von dieser Regelung,
relativ wenige Personen betroffen sein werden, ne? Du müsstest neunzig Tage pro Jahr,
In einem anderen Land sein, in einem in einem europäischen Ausland unterwegs sein, um an diese Grenze zu kommen oder länger als dreißig
am Stück. Es gab irgendwie noch einen Passus, dass es unter Umständen eine Ausnahme geben soll für Pendler,
Ja, die also sich täglich ein und ausbuchen, dass man dann sagt, na gut, der der gute,
Der gute Pendler oder die gute Pendlerin lebt eben an der Grenze im Ausland und muss da irgendwie hin und her. Es gibt da natürlich auch noch so so Sachen, wenn du sehr grenznah wohnst, dann passiert dir das,
Ganz gerne mal, dass du bei der äh Landstraßenfahrt dich mal eben im Ausland einbußt, da wollen sie nochmal ein bisschen gucken,
Aber für, sage ich mal, dass das europäische,
Unternehmen, was jetzt irgendwo unterwegs ist mit dem Business-Verträgen und äh die denen geht da natürlich jetzt erstmal der der entscheidende Vorteil abhanden. Da werden sie aber wahrscheinlich auch wieder Ausnahmeregelungen treffen. Na ja.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall also es sind zwar jetzt nachvollziehbare Einschränkungen sozusagen in der in der aktuellen äh Situation, aber man muss halt auch sagen, äh warum sollte es nicht einen europäischen Wettbewerb über äh Preise äh und und Datenweiterleitungen geben
Weil das ist ja nun genau das, woran es eigentlich auch mangelt und ähm an der Stelle kann man mit dem Roaming natürlich auch so einiges bewegen.
Ja, wir haben ja immer noch das Problem, dass dass der ganze Zugang ähm zu den Netzen ja im Prinzip,
auf nationaler Ebene immer stark reglementiert ist. Also wenn hier in Deutschland halt Anbieter sein willst, dann musst du dich halt auf einen von diesen drei,
Netzbetreibern, die wir äh derzeit haben äh schwingen. Es gibt da nicht ein Netz, was für alle auf die gleiche Art und Weise
zugänglich ist, dieselbe Situation haben wir im Festnetz haben wir schon mehrfach drüber gesprochen, insbesondere der,
immer wieder verkackte Glasfaserausbau kommt halt nicht voran und wenn er halt auch nur irgendwo gedacht wird, dann eben auch meistens so im Sinne von na ja, dann haben wir da hier einen, der jetzt mal eine Glasfaser, was wollt ihr denn?
Dann eben auch noch nicht so richtig. Andere Modelle äh gibt es in Schweden, die es Roming ist ein gewisser Hinsicht der offenste Zugang zu Netzen, weil du,
tauscht halt irgendwo auf, hast mit niemandem einen Vertrag,
Ja, du buchst dich in das bestmögliche Netz ein, was ich dir halt gerade anbietet und überträgst deine Daten und kommunizierst mit deinem Provider. Und das ist eigentlich ist das das Modell wie Internetzugang an sich eben laufen sollte.
Und am Ende werden sich halt die äh Preisstrukturen da halt auch wieder äh einfangen, ne.
Ja, das wäre also was
wenn das so geschehen wäre, ne, das wäre richtig geil für die Verbraucher gewesen, weil damit nämlich die nationalen Quasimonopole und so, die wir jetzt irgendwie gerade abfallen, nochmal so richtig schön unter Druck gesetzt würden. Da wäre ein richtig schöner Preisverfall gewesen,
Und ich mir fällt nur auf, ne? Ganz ehrlich.
Es war ja damals so. Wir wir haben ja das EU-Roaming bekommen als Geschenk im Bündel mit keine Netzneutralität,
Das war damals so, dass gesagt wurde, hier wir machen, wir machen das EU-Roaming und dann haben die Betreiber gesagt, okay, aber dann keine Netzneutralität,
Und jetzt komischerweise ist gerade dieses Netzneutralität äh in in halbwegs trockenen Tüchern. Thomas hat das ja hier ausführlich berichtet,
Und da fällt auch schon wieder das EU-Roaming, ne? Also da da erkenne ich auch glaube ich so.
Muster, eine.
Kenne, ich erkenne ein Muster, ja.
Na ja, also wenn du schon Muster erkennst, sollten wir vielleicht gleich zum nächsten Thema äh kommen, ne? Ist irgendwas passiert?
Es gab zwei interessante Zeitmarken, die wir jetzt nur mal kurz berichten, äh weil sie anerkannt werden müssen. Zehn Jahre Bratenpartei? In Deutschland? Piratenpartei.
Bratenpartei. Piratenpartei, ja?
Zehn Jahre Piratenpartei, da gibt es ein äh ganz interessanten Artikel auf Reise von äh Detlef Borchers, in der äh
mal so ein bisschen rekapituliert, äh womit die Piratenpartei sich im Jahr im Laufe ihrer Zeit so auseinandergesetzt hat, ähm,
das war eigentlich eine ganz schöne, kurze äh Zusammenfassung der Artikel hat den ähm,
äh zehn Jahre Piratenpartei vom Entern, Gendern und Kendern.
Und da gab's ja auch echt Highlights. Also auch einige Sachen, die ich schon wieder vergessen hatte inzwischen, also irgendwie dann eine,
Jörg Haus war da ja auch mal eine Zeit lang dann und er erklärt auch so ein bisschen, was glaube ich ihr Problem war ähm diese diese Analyse.
Teile ich, dass sie irgendwann überrannt wurden von neuen Mitgliedern als diese Hoffnung dann,
nicht die Möglichkeiten hatten, nicht die Strukturen hatten, eine diese Anzahl an Mitgliedern irgendwie in geordnete Bahnen zu lenken und äh gerade durch diesen offenen Diskussions äh Rahmen, den sie an ihren Parteitagen und so hatten und der wir auch,
gut war, aber eben eine riesige äh,
Angriffsfläche für für Trolle äh geboten haben und für Verschwörungstheoretiker und da einfach von einem Hashtag ins nächste gestolpert sind,
Denn der lohnt sich äh zu lesen, ebenso wie das Interview mit Martin Delius, der bei uns ja auch schon mal zu Gast war, der inzwischen äh ja auch, sage ich mal, äh,
den Haar und,
Kopfbehaarungswuchs von Karl Marx hat und äh auch in der entsprechenden Partei inzwischen ist. Das ist kein, das ist ein Kompliment an der Stelle Martin. Der hat ein sehr schönes Interview,
dem geschätzten Jakob Augstein im Freitag. Ja, also ist ja ein wirklich, er hat ein Bad, das ist ja nicht wahr. Das ist schon beeindruckend. Ne?
Wollte mal kurz äh ohne das jetzt zu sehr vertiefen zu wollen, aber finde diesen diesen diesen Blick auf das falsche Wachstum zum falschen Zeitpunkt, finde ich auch ganz interessant, das sehe ich auch so als eins der Probleme an. Und der
Grund dafür, dass das passiert ist, abgesehen davon, dass man vielleicht zu dem Zeitpunkt eben auch,
einerseits nicht genug Aufmerksamkeit hatte für diesen Fakt sich andererseits natürlich auch erheblich da daran erhitzt hat dass man auf einmal wächst ne? Zuspruch und so weiter, Erfolg und so, das macht einen ja immer schnell äh wuschig, wenn man nicht aufpasst,
aber ich glaube der eigentliche Mangel war eben auch so ein bisschen 'n Geburtsfehler insofern als dass man eben auch nicht klar defoniert hat.
Was man denn eigentlich sein wollte. So und dass man eben auch ähm sich.
Was ja auch so ein Problem von von Protestbewegungen an sich ist, dass sie sich zunächst einmal ein bisschen mehr darüber definieren, was sie alles nicht sein wollen,
Ja, dass man einfach so klare äh Feindbilder am Start hat und und Dinge halt irgendwie ablehnt.
Und ähm andere Leute dieser dieser Ablehnung dann sozusagen leicht beitreten können, aber dann eben mit ihren anderen Vorstellungen kommen, was sie denn sonst noch so gerne hätten und sich da dann eben zeigt
Dass das äh dass man in dieser vereinten Ablehnung eben nicht zwangsläufig auch gleichzeitig äh eine einheitliche Linie für was man eben haben will ähm aufmacht und
da ist, dann so ein bisschen zu spät, glaube ich, die Reißleine gezogen worden, bevor man eben einerseits eine stabile Basis hatte und bevor man sich eben auch stabile ähm,
Regelwerke vielleicht gegeben hat oder zumindest einen Modus äh äh gefunden hat,
in dem dieser Diskurs ablaufen soll, wohin sich eben diese ganze Partei Geschichte entwickeln soll. Und dann war's halt irgendwann auch zu spät. So, da war es dann einfach nicht mehr einzuholen. Da war dann eben auch schon so viel
Behaarungs ähm Bereitschaft diesen
unguten, chaotischen Zustand, in dem eigentlich dann keine sinnvolle Entscheidung mehr gefällt werden konnte beizubehalten. Alles wurde dann sozusagen nur noch als
und als ja Grabenkampf bezeichnet, was es ja dann auch wirklich war,
Ja und dann hat sie dann deine äh ganzen äh Grüppchen, die sich äh aufs Härteste befeindet haben und das muss man auch sagen, liebe Piraten. Also ich kenne ja.
Ich habe ja eine Menge von euch kennengelernt und ich weiß, da sind viele,
kluge Leute oder waren zumindest viele viele kluge Leute unterwegs, sind auch noch einige kluge Leute geblieben, die Motivation nicht so ganz teile.
Aber dieser äh diese Auseinandersetzung, die war einfach.
Sehr ungut in der in der in der in der Außenwahrnehmung so und ich glaub das ist intern
wurde das teilweise gar nicht so sehr verstanden,
wie abschreckend das gewirkt hat. Und wie wie wenig man irgendwann damit irgendwie noch zu tun haben wollte. Und das war äh sicherlich ein Problem und das lässt sich für meinen Geschmack eben auch nicht,
nicht mehr einfangen. Amen.
Haben wir doch mit Rohr geredet.
Ja, wir haben noch eine Marke.
Die digitale Agenda. Zwei Jahre, was ist denn das schon? Und irgendwas passiert?
Äh ja, also wir haben ja die die blühende Landschaften wurden uns ja versprochen und ähm.
Jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen, wo so wo sind sie denn.
Ja, weiß nicht, ich habe hier immer noch fünfzig Megabit, hat sich irgendwie nichts getan letzten zwei Ja.
Das hatte Markus auch glaube ich in seinem Artikel auseinandergenommen der Breitwandausbau, wie war das irgendwie flächendeckend fuffzig Mbit war ja glaube ich das ambitionierte Ziel, ne?
Aber irgendwie in zehn Jahren oder so, ne?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das war gar nicht so. Äh ich müsste jetzt nochmal da muss mal ganz kurz schauen,
Äh digitale äh Gender. Der Markus hatte das nämlich sehr schön sogar mit Mitprozentzahlen und so. Ähm.
Ausgerechnet.
Ja, es wurden immer irgendwelche Zieljahre ausgegeben und dann mal schnell auch nochmal um zwei, drei Jahre nach hinten geschoben und die auch die Prozentzahl, die man erreichen wollte, wurden alle nicht erreicht.
Also Dobrindt hat erklärt, dass bereits siebzig Prozent der Haushalte über fünfzig Mbit verfügen. Und das Ziel zwanzig achtzehn könnte erreicht werden.
Ja, der äh also Markus sagt zweitausendneun hatte Merkel schon versprochen, dass zweitausendvierzehn fünfundsiebzig Prozent äh fünfzig Mbit haben sollten. Zweitausendelf hatte sie das wiederholt, ein.
Eingehalten wurde es nicht,
Na dann haben wir ein ähm IT-Sicherheitsgesetz gehabt, äh wer dazu äh habe ich meine Meinung hier glaube ich ausführlich
Kundgetan, ich hatte das ja damals als Sachverständiger im Innenausschuss äh ähm nochmal bewertet.
Die Stellungnahme gibt's auf CCC DE. Ähm ich habe,
Dann jetzt kann ich vielleicht noch ein bisschen erzählen.
In dieser Woche ein eine Veranstaltung besucht, in der es äh um die,
Sicherheit kritischer Infrastrukturen ging.
Und da habe ich damit mich mit einem Vertreter der Bundesnetzagentur unterhalten und äh habe dann mal so ein bisschen Zahlen bekommen, wie sich denn jetzt so die Stadtwerke,
die ja auch unter kritische Infrastrukturen fallen, äh wie die sich denn jetzt so absichern,
Und in dem Falle der Stadtwerke ist ein, ich hatte ja prognostiziert, ähm,
bei den bei den größeren Betreibern ist es ja so, dass gesagt wird, okay, ihr kriegt vorgeschriebene Sicherheitsregeln, die euch,
Im Prinzip vom Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der vom Informationstechnik vorgeschrieben werden? Sicherheitskonzepte,
Aber was diese Konzepte sein werden, dafür habt ihr ein Vorschlagsrecht und zwar als Verband,
Das heißt, ne, du hast jetzt, wenn du jetzt im Mobilfunkbereich gehst, die drei großen Mobilfunkprovider, äh die gehen dann hin
definieren ein gemeinsames Sicherheitskonzept, das heißt sie schreiben das auf was sie ohnehin alle machen
und dann werden sie vom Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Firma Informationstechnik dazu verpflichtet, das auch zu tun, was sie ohnehin schon machen und dann ist viel Papier beschrieben worden,
und dann ist es dann äh ist es äh IT-Sicherheitsgesetz erfolgreich umgangen worden, ja? Ist viel viele Ressourcen gefressen, aber nichts passiert. Und bei den.
Bei einigen Bereichen ist es eben so, dass sie unter die B Netz A fallen. Und wie gesagt haben, nee, pass auf. Unser Regulierungsansprechpartner äh bleibt bitteschön einer. Wir haben keine Lust, uns hier jetzt mit dem ähm.
Mit dem PSI und mit der BNI auseinanderzusetzen. Wir machen das alles schön über die BNI und die BNZA dann eben äh die Netze halt bekommen und hat dann mal ein ein Sicherheitskonzept geschrieben, weil bei den ganzen,
ähm bei den ganzen Kraftwerk äh bei den ganzen äh Stadtwerken, die können ja jetzt die
nicht alle zusammensetzen, sagen wir mal ein gemeinsames Sicherheitskonzept. Also hat äh
ist die Bundesnetzagentur hingegangen und hat neuen neuen Zertifizierungsstandard erhoben, weil wenn man eins braucht in der IT-Sicherheit, dann ist das halt noch ein Zertifizierungsstandard, ja? Da gibt's also einfach zu wenige noch äh um,
um einfach so ein bisschen auch eine Auswahl zu haben, ne? Und äh deswegen hat die BNI dann auch nochmal einen formuliert,
und es sieht doch tatsächlich relativ düster aus, dass der äh in näherer Zeit von allen Stadtwerken angenommen wird. Da habe ich also da muss ich sagen, sehr schockierende,
Zahlen eher gehört, was jetzt so die Idee angeht, überhaupt mal ein bisschen Governance aufzubauen über die äh Sicherheit der IT-Systeme, ja? Also ein,
ISMS zu haben, Information, Security Management System darüber denken dann der Großteil der.
Stadtwerke jetzt inzwischen auch mal nach. Ja, das heißt, sie fahren zu großen Teilen ohne überhaupt ein,
eine ein Managementkonzept für IT-Sicherheit zu haben und das ist natürlich dann doch ein bisschen.
Tja. Also mit euren Worten Breitband gibt's nicht, Sicherheit gibt's auch nicht. Nee. Störerhaftung.
Sollte abgeschafft werden weiß noch keiner.
Weiß noch keiner, ob's passiert ist.
Verschlüsselung, Standort Nummer eins, wollten wir auch noch werden. Da sind wir auf dem besten Wege, denn es gibt ja jetzt die Zitis, die die ganze Verschlüsselung wieder knacken soll.
Ja, also man ist dann aber verstehst du, das ist das ist einfach in gewisser Hinsicht genial. Man wird sozusagen Verschlüsselungsstandardnummern und vielleicht auch Entschlüsselungsstandort Nummer eins,
Also ich meine, ich bezweifle die Nummer eins in beiderlei äh Hinsicht. Ja, das ist vielleicht irgendwie eine ja gut, also im Bereich Verschlüsselung würde ich, würde ich,
Deutschland prinzipiell irgendwie die Top Five äh zutrauen, aber bestimmt nicht im Endschlüsseln.
Es ist ähm ja also diese, das ist schon ziemlich genau das ähm.
Aber es gibt auch gute Nachrichten.
Ja, es gibt keinen Routerzwang mehr. Das hat das war ein Versprechen der digitalen Agenda und das ist hat stattgefunden,
Es gibt auch ähm,
wie ein Funding Projekt für Open Aducational Resources. Das wäre natürlich sehr schön. Ähm es gibt das Verband klagerecht im Datenschutz. Also das wird nochmal äh spannend bei äh Datenschutzverletzungen,
Und Markus führt das auch auf in seinem Artikel bei Netzpolitik Org, dass es äh den Prototyp Fund gibt und ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir den hier in Logbuch Netzwerk schon beworben.
Nein, den haben wir ja noch nicht beworben.
Dann tun wir das jetzt,
Und zwar äh Ohren auf, der Prototyp fand ist eine sehr äh interessante Initiative des BMWI wird aber quasi umgesetzt durch die Open-Nollage Foundation,
Und es gibt noch vierzehn Tage sich dort zu bewerben mit Open Source Projekten, die schon von mir aus,
Gerade noch in der kommt konkreten
Planungsphase sind oder die schon erste Mile Stones erreicht haben und jetzt quasi weitere Erweiterungen suchen für ihr Projekt und da gibt es ähm,
insgesamt glaube ich eins Komma sonst was Millionen Euro, die da verteilt werden und es gibt immer quasi eine Funding,
Runde ist immer dreißigtausend Euro und da kann man sich mit seinem ähm Open Source Projekt
bewerben. Das Bewerbungsformular verlinken wir auch. Ich kann jetzt noch
Darauf hinweisen ähm Deadline ist der äh ich glaube Ende September, also genauso wie Einreichung zum dreiunddreißig C drei ist das, glaube ich. Und also da müsstet ihr jetzt mal möglichst schnell eure Einreichungen machen,
Und das ist natürlich schon eine ganz feine Sache für so Open Source Projekte, die mal ein bisschen in Schwung zu bringen. Äh es gibt da verschiedene,
Themenbereiche in denen äh dieses Funding dann angeboten wird, also man.
Gibt schon einen gewissen Schwerpunkt jetzt zumindest in dieser erst
in der ersten Phase und der ist, sagen wir mal, auch sehr in der in der Tradition der bisherigen Tätigkeit, der UKF äh angesiedelt, ne? Also so Bürger äh Tools, so fragt den Start
mäßig äh ja äh Systeme, die halt visualisieren, Nutzung äh von Daten
machen, das läuft unter dem Begriff Data Literacy, dann halt Datensicherheit, also Fokus auf Privatsphäre, sichere Kommunikation, der Klassiker, Datensparsamkeit
beziehungsweise dann Softwareinfrastruktur, aber wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, zieht sich das eben primär auf Werkzeuge, die eben
diese ersten drei Kategorien im Wesentlichen auch stützen, ne? Also im Kern kann man sagen, es geht eigentlich um drei
Kernbereiche zunächst einmal und steht jetzt nicht grundsätzlich allen Sachen offen, andererseits ist glaube ich auch der Run auf das Projekt schon ziemlich ausgeprägt und von daher
muss man dann die nächsten Runden abwarten. Das ist jetzt sozusagen nicht die Deadline und dann ist es vorbei, sondern es ist nur die erste Deadline von mehreren Deadlines, weil es halt verschiedene Phasen gibt und je nachdem wie gut das angenommen wird, muss man halt mal sehen, inwiefern das BMWI da noch bereit ist, da zu legen und aufzustocken, zu verlängern, et cetera.
Disclaimer, äh wir sind mit mehreren Leuten, die an diesem Prototyp Fund arbeiten, sehr.
Regelmäßig stehen wir an Bars und trinken Bier.
Regelmäßig sehr regelmäßigen, teilweise sehr engen Kontakten und ich werde auch ähm,
da ähm ein bisschen meiner Beratungen einfließen lassen, was die Sicherheitskonzepte angeht. Ich bin nicht in der offiziellen Jury, aber ich werde da ein paar Einschätzungen zugeben.
Also könnte er eigentlich vergessen, ja, was.
Nein, aber das, das ist wirklich, das ist wirklich ein, das freut mich sehr.
Aber wir tun zumindest mal so, als wäre da was möglich so.
Wegen der Befangenheit konnte ich das ja gar nicht so sehr bewerben, wie ich's gerne wollte und das ist wirklich ähm das ist wirklich eine eine feine Sache und da sollte man mit seinem Projekt äh drangehen. Da kann man, ne, kann man nochmal so einen Boost kriegen.
Ja das bringt uns zu äh unserer Lieblingssektion, nämlich den Termin.
Ja und diesmal äh gibt's auch ordentlich was zu äh berichten, denn äh unter anderem steht ein kleines Jubiläum an, nämlich äh der CTC äh Überraschung wird fünfunddreißig Jahre alt.
Ist schon, ist schon.
Ist schon fünfunddreißig Jahre alt äh geworden. Das war am zwölften September und ähm ja, da gibt's dann einen kleinen Grillabend äh zu Beginn in äh Hamburg, also wenn ihr in Hamburg wohnt oder die Gelegenheit habt, dort hinzukommen äh
Heute ist Freitag, wir nehmen das auf, morgen ist äh Samstag, der siebzehnte neunte, ab einundzwanzig Uhr im Keller der Viktoriakaserne, dem sogenannten Frapant
Und da geht man über den Hof, Bodenstedtstraße sechzehn und ja seid äh dabei. Wenn ihr die Gelegenheit habt.
Es wurde ja schon angekündigt, aber einige Sachen kündigen wir einfach mehrmals an. Das ist die, das ist Netzpolitikkonferenz am siebten Oktober in der Kulturbrauerei,
Karten gibt's für alle möglichen Preise, kann man sich einen aussuchen äh den Link zwölf Punkt Netzpolitik Punkt org findet ihr auch nochmal in den Shownotes.
Ich hatte mit äh Andre gewitzelt, dass äh der Name irgendwie
schwierig zu merken wäre in den Kommentaren gab's den Vorschlag, die Veranstaltung einfach P gleich MP zu nennen. Äh die Nerds haben jetzt gelacht. Der Rest ignoriert das einfach.
Ja, ein weiterer Termin ist der vierzehnte bis sechzehnte Oktober, da gibt's nämlich in München, das ist jetzt hier Eigenwerbung, gibt's die äh Podcaster Konferenz Subscribe äh Nummer acht, da äh werde ich dann im Nachgang auch nochmal was zu sagen.
Und in Konstanz gibt es jetzt auch einen Chaos-Treff. Ihr wisst, der Chaostreff ist die Vorstufe des R-Fahrerkreises, der des Chaos-Computerclubs. Jeden zweiten Dienstag um neunzehn Uhr
In den Räumlichkeiten des Hackerspace, Hecknology EV. Ähm weitere Informationen unter Hecknology DE. Der Verein ist frisch gegründet und seit diesem Sommer mit fünfzehn Mitgliedern aktiv.
Und last but not least äh auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, aber äh kann man nicht oft genug erwähnen, vom siebenundzwanzigsten bis zum dreißigsten Dezember natürlich der
Dreiunddreißigste Chaos-Communication-Kongress der dreiunddreißig C drei im CCH in äh Hamburg und ja da wollt ihr wahrscheinlich hin.
Und wie hin, wie man da jetzt hinkommt. Das sollten wir jetzt vielleicht nochmal erwähnen.
Ja, es gab äh,
die Herausforderungen ja im letzten Jahr beim zweiunddreißig C drei, dass diese Veranstaltung dann erstmalig wieder äh bis an die Latten ausverkauft war und die es sehr viel Nachfrage nach Tickets gab und ähm.
Was ja, was ja wirklich also sowohl,
Erfreulich ist, als auch ein gewisser Hinsicht ein bisschen bestürzend, weil ein paar Jahre zuvor äh zum neunundzwanzig C drei haben wir ja Berlin verlassen, nachdem sich mehrere Jahre lang hintereinander so eine Situation auch in Berlin schon eingestellt hatte und einfach äh alles nicht mehr zu ertragen war
Dann hatte man diesen Befreiungsschlag und dann innerhalb von drei Jahren äh
kamen jedes Jahr nochmal dreitausend Leute obendrauf und jetzt waren wir dann halt letztes Jahr schon,
ja an der Grenze, wo es dann irgendwann keine Tickets mehr gab und das ist eigentlich so 'ne Situation, die wir eigentlich nicht haben wollen
andererseits, die jetzt aber auch da ist, die sich auch nicht vermeiden lässt, weil es gibt einfach nur mal eine, eine, eine maximalen Füllstand in diesem Gebäude und den muss man respektieren und äh es wurde nun lange darüber nachgedacht, wie man damit umgeht, weil
Man könnte ja verschiedene Ansätze wählen. Ja, natürlich der Klassiker ist äh,
Das hatten wir im Prinzip letztes Jahr und das führt dann eben zu unbefriedigenden Zuständen.
Deswegen haben wir uns dann überlegt, was äh wie man eine ähm Verteilung dieser Tickets,
machen kann, die ja ein bisschen sicherstellt, dass auch die Veranstaltung selber in ihrem Kern,
auch so ein bisschen weiterlebt, ja? Und ähm wie man vielleicht auch Leute, die zu diesen Veranstaltungen beigetragen haben,
in in einer gewissen Form anerkennen kann, ja? Und äh die,
Methode, für die wir uns jetzt nach langem überlegen entschieden haben ist, dass es eine Art Vorvorverkauf gibt. Also die,
Wir reden von einer Anzahl N-Tickets. Ich weiß noch nicht mal genau, wie groß die jetzt gerade ist. Ähm,
Von dieser werden fünfzig Prozent der Tickets.
In einem Vorvorverkauf verkauft und danach in die zweite Hälfte der Tickets in einem,
in dem offenen, freien Verkauf, wie man ihn kennt, First come, first, surft.
Und die Idee des Vorvorverkaufes ist jenen, die sich in dieser Konferenz in dieser Veranstaltung eingebracht haben, die dort geholfen haben, die Möglichkeit eines Vorkaufes zu äh ermöglichen. Das heißt, dem wird die Sorge genommen,
eventuell kein Ticket zu bekommen. Das funktioniert also so, dass,
Die Engel, die im letzten Jahr äh ausreichend viele Engelschichten gemacht haben, dass sie ein T-Shirt bekommen haben, jetzt so ein,
Wautscher bekommen haben, mit diesen Wautscher können sie dann ein Ticket kaufen und wenn der Wortschatz eingelöst und bezahlt ist, können sie kriegen sie noch einen Wortschein, damit kann dann
Können Sie eine Begleitung äh freuen, Freundin ihrer Wahl nochmal den Kauf eines Tickets ermöglichen? So stellen wir halt äh so ein bisschen die Wertschätzung der Engel wieder, weil es natürlich
schon auch bitter und verständlich, wenn du irgendwie beim zweiunddreißig C drei warst, da sagen wir um die um die zehn Arbeitsstunden geleistet hast, als Teil dieser Veranstaltung äh dazu beigetragen hast und dann auf einmal beim dreiunddreißig C drei einfach leer ausgehst, weil nicht schnell genug auf dem Ticket klingen konntest.
Genau. Und außerdem kannst du deine Begeisterung halt auch gleich noch in den Freundeskreis tragen und irgendwie die Lieblingsperson äh einfach mit reinholen, die das vielleicht bisher noch nicht gesehen hat.
Genau und ähm.
Gleiches gilt für Sprecher, gleiches gilt dann auch noch für das Umfeld. Was immer sehr schwer zu definieren ist,
Aber da sind wir dann einfach losgegangen und haben einfach mal
äh Erfolgsreise des CCs, äh befreundete äh Hackerspaces, äh vergleichbare Orte, aktivistische äh Gruppen. Also was man eben so als Umfeld definiert ausgemacht und auch dort,
entsprechende Angebote gemacht, das heißt wenn ihr,
der Meinung seid, dass ihr diesem Umfeld so nahe steht, dass er unbedingt in diesem Vorvor-Vorverkauf äh im Prinzip auch schon ähm die Möglichkeit erhalten solltet, da mitzuspielen,
dann geht doch da einfach mal hin, wo ihr euch äh angedockt fühlt, wenn ihr sozusagen äh ohnehin schon in so einem lokalen Kulturraum äh dabei seid,
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass wenn ihr dort hingeht, dass ihr dann eben auch Zugriff auf so einen Baujob-Code bekommt.
Ja, die sind also tatsächlich die Wautscher sind nicht besonders ähm,
Also sie wollen jetzt nicht besonders spärlich an die jeweiligen Gruppen gegeben und es sollte eigentlich, denke ich,
wenn man halbwegs einen Zugang zu dieser weitgefassten Community hat, äh möglich sein,
Also ein Wauter zu kommen. Und selbst wenn das nicht so ist, ähm wird es dann natürlich auch im weiteren Nachgang äh denke ich sehr,
noch vor einiger Zeit möglich sein in dem äh freien Verkauf Tickets zu bekommen. Also das da ist schon,
Einiges möglich, man kann natürlich auch einen Talk einreichen. Damit hat man ja dann auch die Garantie, die Veranstaltung zu besuchen, wenn der äh Talk angenommen wird. Da gibt's also viele Möglichkeiten. Natürlich freut sich da jetzt keiner drüber zu äh,
dass es wahrscheinlich eben darauf hinauslaufen wird, dass irgendwo dann eben auch Menschen leer ausgehen und die sind dann immer persönlich getroffen, aber,
Es gibt eben einfach.
Nicht genug Tickets für die, die anfragen, aber wir hatten im Prin.
Nicht genug Platz in diesem Raum, ne? Also das ist ja schon der größte Erhäl.
Wir wissen jetzt nicht so ganz genau, wie das ausgeht, aber ähm und auch nochmal klarzustellen, wie das alles gemeint ist. Also es geht hier nicht da drum,
so 'ne Mauer um so 'ne Community zu bauen und wir wollen uns unter uns bleiben. Darum geht's nicht. Dann hätte man sozusagen alle Tickets nur über so ein Wortschatzsystem rausgegeben und das wäre sicherlich keine gute Idee
Weil dann, dann, dann, dann schmorst du natürlich nur in dem eigenen Saft. Äh wir wissen, dass der Kongress sich nur dann positiv weiterentwickeln kann, wenn er sowohl
von einer,
ähm über viele Jahre gewachsenen und mitlernenden Gemeinschaft getragen werden kann, die auch in der Lage sind, eben diese ganzen Erfahrungen der vergangenen Jahre weiterzugeben,
als auch immer wieder eine neue Durchmischung zu haben mit mit Newcomern, mit Leuten, die das erste Mal sind oder die vielleicht auch nur alle Jahre äh mal die Gelegenheit haben oder auch nur Lust haben, da mal reinzuschauen. Leute, die wir eben.
Am Ende dieser Versorgungskette sehen wollen, sind halt Leute, die eigentlich äh diesen Event gar nicht so sehr äh verstehen. Da gab's dann auch wirklich äh teilweise manchmal so ganz ob Skure äh,
Grüppchen, die.
Diesen Kongress überhaupt gar nicht geteilt haben, aber so irgendwie aus aus dritter Quelle dann so gesteckt bekommen haben. Das wäre ja eine ganz interessante Messe. Noch ob's pure E-Mails äh hinschreiben mit ja, wir haben ja jetzt,
erworben und können wir denn da äh wo wo bauen wir denn unseren Stand auf und so? Wollen wir halt auch so Leute. Also das.
Und das schmerzt, das schmerzt natürlich wirklich, wenn du.
Wenn dann andere das nicht nicht reingekommen.
Traurig zu Hause sitzen und äh streamen gucken.
Genau und und genau diesen diesen Effekt wollen wir einfach oben drehen. Also wir wollen sozusagen sicherstellen, dass
die Leute, die wir dort auch wirklich haben wollen und diese sich dort heimisch fühlen, auch die Gelegenheit haben jetzt in diesem Prozess bis Ende Oktober äh sich diesen Ticket zu sichern, dass auch frühzeitig äh sichern zu können
dann äh gibt es halt eine breite Öffnung und Streuung und sicherlich wird's äh den einen oder anderen Herdfall dann wieder äh geben müssen, aber vielleicht ist das Gesamtverhältnis dann in einem gesünderen Maße
als es sich jetzt wahrscheinlich ergeben hätte, würden wir jetzt einfach von vornherein die Tore aufmachen und dieser Run dann halt losgeht. Ja, das mal so zur Erklärung. Also.
Ich sehe übrigens, dass es auch ganz gute, also in verschiedenen äh Foren, äh sei es Twitter, auch ganz guten Austausch gibt, weil viele
Engel zum Beispiel dann ihr Plus eins verschenken, weil sie eh in einer Gruppe sind, wo alle geedelt haben, sage ich
brauche jetzt hier, ich habe ein Plus eins gerade mal zu vergeben, das sehe ich also eigentlich einen relativ regen äh Austausch da. Also es sollte eigentlich nicht so schwierig sein, an so einen Wortschatz zu kommen.
Bin ihr Wort schon kurz auf eBay stellt, dann äh sind wir nicht so froh.
Dann kaufen wir die und kommen die abholen. So, dann äh gibt's aber noch was. Alle gibt's noch andere Konferenz, da gibt's nichts ohne Wautscher.
Genau, ich hatte es ja vorhin schon erwähnt, die äh Subscribe acht, das ist ja äh fortgesetzte äh Teil unserer Community Konferenz, die auch immer noch eine Community Konferenz sein soll,
da geht's halt äh primär um Podcasting oder ich sage mal vielleicht etwas allgemeiner gefasst, auch ums Veröffentlichen von ähm Audioinhalten im Netz. Wir wollen da auch ein bisschen äh breiter das Ganze anlegen. Bisher war diese Veranstaltung immer in Berlin,
und wir hatten jetzt vor einiger Zeit schon das Angebot bekommen, doch mal nach München zu gehen und zwar vom Bayerischen Rundfunk. Das haben wir gerne angenommen,
weil das im Wesentlichen einen kommt doch mal vorbei benutzt doch mal hier unseren.
Unsere Räumlichkeiten for free und macht auch mal eure Konferenz hier in dem Kontext, da haben wir dann einfach ja gesagt und so wird es jetzt auch sein. Also vom vierzehnten bis zum sechzehnten Oktober,
Nummer acht und ja
Wer Lust hat, da äh mitzumachen, äh ist herzlich eingeladen, dazu zu kommen. Es gibt da einen kleinen Obolus, den man abgeben muss, aber das ist im Wesentlichen die Bezahlung des Essens. Wir besorgen halt wieder mal
angenehmes Essen, sodass man da hingeht und dass ich eigentlich überhaupt gar keine Gedanken machen muss und sich einfach nur interessante Talks
anhören kann, Berichte aus der Community, aber eben auch Berichte so aus ein bisschen aus der Außenwelt, wir erwarten, dass wir, sagen wir mal, einen thematischen Querschnitt haben, der jetzt noch weit über den
diese äh Kernpodcasting-Community Szene hinausgeht
schlicht und ergreifend, weil wir natürlich dort auch den Kontakt mit dem öffentlichen Rundfunk auch bewusst äh suchen und mal schauen, was da so bei rauskommt
gibt viel Technik, es gibt aber vor allem auch viel Inhaltliches, es gibt viel,
äh Meterdiskussion, aber vor allem gibt's immer sehr interessante Leute, weil und das habe ich halt auch äh stelle ich auch immer wieder mit Begeisterung fest. Diese ganze Podcastlandschaft ist halt einfach voll mit Leuten, die
Einerseits 'ne Menge zu erzählen haben oder zumindest in der Lage sind andere Leute viel erzählen zu lassen.
Das gefällt dir, ne?
Und die
Mitteilungsbedürfnis, aber auch eine Mitteilungsfähigkeit haben. Also man begibt sich auch automatisch einfach in so ein äh eine Umgebung, in der einfach
sehr schön kommuniziert wird, ja? Klare Ausdrucksweisen, also Kommunikationsfreudige äh äh Gruppe. Ja und wer schon immer mal überlegt hat, vielleicht auch zum Pott Love Workshop zu kommen,
Damals oder eben der Subscribe äh sieben jetzt zuletzt in Berlin, aber sich gedacht hat, hm, Berlin. Ich wohne ja im Süden. Äh ja, es ist herzlich eingeladen,
auf die Subscribe acht in München zu kommen in den Räumen des bayrischen Rundfunks äh vierzehnter bis sechzehnter Oktober und ja, wir hätten euch gerne dabei.
Was kostet das.
Na ja, man kann den Preis so ein bisschen wählen, wir haben so drei Ticketkategorien, es gibt so quasi so einen Normalpreis,
der bei hundert Euro liegt für die drei Tage Versorgung, also mit Frühstück, Abendessen und so weiter, Getränke, alles komplett enthalten,
und man kann äh den Preis aber auch gerne um zwanzig Euro absenken, wenn man das für angemessen hält. Man kann auch gerne um zwanzig äh Euro anheben
Damit finanziert man diese günstigen Tickets mit, das ist so ein Modell, das machen wir schon seit Längerem, das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut
und wer ohnehin über 'ne Businesskasse verfügt und sich über solche Teilnahmepreise nur wundert, für den haben wir dann noch 'n paar andere Tickets zum Klicken wo man auch gerne noch ein bisschen
mehr Überschuss produzieren kann. Ansonsten ist das Ganze eine Null-Summen-Spiel für uns im Wesentlichen, wir sind froh, wenn wir unsere Kosten dann eben auch sicher gedeckelt bekommen haben
da verdient jetzt keiner groß Geld dran, wir wollen da einfach eine schöne Party haben, einen korrekten Wissensaustausch,
fördern und ich denk das ist nicht nur interessant für Podcaster ist generell für Leute die einfach sich mit Medien und Medienwirkung beschäftigen ganz interessant und vielleicht eben auch für den ein oder anderen Hörer,
Wenn man da sozusagen Lust hat, mal ein bisschen näher an das Ganze Geschehen heranzugehen. Link in den Shownotes.
Ja, dann haben wir noch eine Postkarte bekommen hier. Von.
Potcaste, eine Postkaste.
Podcast äh habe ich Podcast gesagt.
Postkarte von Klaus. Ich lese mal vor, was? Ja. Ja, lieber Linus, lieber Tim. Guten Morgen ihr zwei.
Kleiner Gruß aus dem Urlaub. Was auch ein Urlaub von Lokbuch Netzpolitik ist, was ich gerade nicht höre, sonst aber fieberhaft,
damit ich euch zufolge zweihundert eingeholt habe,
Zur Zeit bin ich noch irgendwo bei hundertsechzig oder hundertsiebzig, aber immerhin schon zwanzig sechzehn. Verrückt, oder?
Vielen lieben Dank für jede einzelne höchstinformative Sendung. Klaus. Sehr schön Klaus. Und du glaubst gar nicht, wie sehr uns diese Karte äh in die Hände.
In Panik versetzt.
Das auch.
Scheiße, Scheiße, Scheiße.
Scheiße. Zweihundert, weil jetzt äh lauscht ihr ja der hundertfünfundneunzigsten und dann haben wir mal so ein bisschen unseren Terminplan ausgerollt und mal so geguckt, sag mal, wann ist denn eigentlich die zweihundertste,
Und dann lächelte uns gleich noch ein anderes Datum an,
Das nämlich ganz gut zusammenfiel, denn am achtundzwanzigsten zehnten ist quasi rein technisch gesehen äh fünf Jahre dieses Programm on R.
Und die zweihundertste Folge.
Und die zweihundertste Folge wurde im Prinzip auch so an dieses äh Wochenende hin äh fallen, sodass wir jetzt,
beschlossen haben, alle äh Aktivitäten zu entfalten
um vielleicht mal was Besonderes zu machen, was auch unsere sonstigen Speziale noch ein wenig übersteigt
Wir wollen also mit euch feiern, wir wollen irgendwie fünf Jahre Lokbuchnetzpolitik machen, wir wollen das mit der zweihundertsten Folge machen. Wir wollen es in Berlin machen,
Wir wollen es voraussichtlich.
Gewissen Einschränkungen, dass das noch alles nicht hundertprozentig in trockenen Tüchern ist, aber wir werden euch natürlich darüber äh fortlaufend in Kenntnis setzen, wie der Hase läuft, voraussichtlich,
Samstag den neunundzwanzigsten Oktober tun wollen und,
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir so sehr viel mehr sagen können, es wird eine Livesendung äh geben. Es wird.
Es wird eine, es wird eine Gala.
Es wird eine Gala, es wird Dinge geben, die vielleicht über diese Live-Sendung hinaus äh gehen und nicht nur viel leichter, sondern es wird Dinge geben, die über diese Live-Sendung hinausgehen. Es wird im Anschluss auf jeden Fall auch noch eine Party geben.
Mit Musik.
Also eine richtige Party, nicht so eine Party-Party, sondern halt so eine so eine Party-Party. Äh und das halt alles so im Signature Berlin Style, wie wir's gerne haben,
Also macht euch schon mal ein Kreuz an dem Wochenende,
Irgendwann wird man dafür Tickets erwerben können. Wir können euch leider auch zu den Preisen noch nichts sagen, weil wir irgendwie Location Preise kosten, Kalkulation, Aufwand und so weiter, noch nicht so ganz im Blick haben, werden aber auf jeden Fall Eintritt nehmen müssen, das ist klar.
Schon mal anzusparen.
Genau, fang schon mal an zu sparen, legt mal jede Woche einen Zehner weg.
Man kann ja auch vielleicht gibt's ja vor Ort dann auch äh die eine oder andere Touristenfalle noch.
Ja die werden nochmal einbauen. Also wir werden euch äh Woche und Woche über unsere Fortschritte in in dieser Hinsicht ähm in Kenntnis setzen und in dem Moment, wo man dann eben auch mal was klicken kann, sagen wir dann Bescheid. Also äh sagt alle Termine ab
Ne? Entschuldigt euch bei euren Lebenspartnern oder packt sie einfach mit ein und,
Macht euch da schon mal einen großen Klingel, um dieses Wochenende. Da gibt's ja in Berlin immer was Interessantes, äh drumherum äh von daher lohnt sich das.
So schade wie viel will man verraten, ne? Also wie viel will man jetzt sagen, was so was so geplant ist, so ich weiß nicht, wie wie viele Wochen ich da jetzt noch an mich halten kann, äh was wir da schon alles irgendwie für Ideen.
Fünf Wochen lang wirst du an dich halten.
Fünf Wochen lang Fresse halten. Ja.
Ja. Wusste.
Ja, werde ich sowieso.
Ja, weil sonst gibt's Ärger von mir. Wir werden sicherlich mehr äh äh etwas konkreter werden, aber ähm ja. Wir wollen's diesmal richtig krachen da.
Es wird äh Sondergäste geben, es wird äh Musik geben, es wird lange gehen.
Es wird ein schöner Ort sein.
Asset ein verflucht schöner Ort sein, was noch ja mehr sagen wir nicht. Mehr sagen wir nicht. Oh jo.
Mehr sagen wir erstmal nicht. Mehr sagen wir, nur nur nur nur gegen Bestechung.
Ach so und ähm wenn ihr ähm Ideen habt, was Gute, ne, bitte nur gute Ideen.
Was ihr meint, was vielleicht so äh in so einem Galaabend unter Umständen noch witziges oder tolles oder Beeindruckendes passieren könnte und ob ihr da sozusagen auch was,
zu beizutragen hätte.
Oder wenn ihr einen Messestand buchen wollt.
Also wir wollen jetzt nicht einfach nur irgendwelche Ideen mit Macht nochmal das und das und so weiter davon haben wir genug. Nee, wenn ihr sozusagen wenn ihr was Konkretes habt, was äh.
Euch.
Könnten Waffeleis.
Was? Nee, was euch auch schon immer so im im Kopf herumschwebt oder was ihr schon immer mal machen wolltet und und und was ihr irgendwann uns vielleicht mal sowieso gezeigt äh präsentiert oder geschenkt oder zur Verfügung gestellt hättet. Vielleicht ist das dann der richtige Zeitpunkt, also schreibt uns einfach dann
eine Mail
dann gucken wir uns das an und schauen, ob das sich in irgendeiner Form äh mit anderen Dingen vielleicht erfolgreich kombinieren lässt oder für sich genommen äh eine Attraktion darstellt, ähm
nur ernst gemeinte Zuschriften bitte.
Nur ernst gemeinte Zuschriften, kaufmännische Angebote mit entsprechenden Bedingungen,
Nein, aber ist, ja, wenn äh vielleicht habt ihr ja auch noch eine schöne Idee, was man einfließen lassen könnte in so ein, in so einer Gala.
Und äh das mit dem Waffeleisen und der Ausstellerfläche war, also es gibt dann auch vielleicht die Möglichkeit, wenn man da den lokalen Hacksface nochmal aufbauen möchte, weil man gerade irgendwie mit dem Kernfusionsreaktor sehr
kurz vor der Vollendung ist und da eigentlich nur noch ein bisschen Leute, die Marteflaschen halten müssen. Äh da kann man ja auch mal drüber reden.
Irgendwas vielleicht gibt's ja irgendwas lustiges, was so.
Okay, kommt erstmal mit euren Ideen und wir begutachten das und dann schauen wir mal weiter.
Aber wo, jetzt, vor allem, wo an diese E-Mail-Adresse, ne.
P at mit der Ebene Punkt DME.
Okay, LMP Endmeterebene Punkt ME. Ist noch keine Mail gekommen.
Genau. Da schickt er das hin. Ne? Jetzt nochmal. Mach nochmal Reload. Ach so, die Sendung ist noch ganz ne.
Dann hatten wir jetzt so von diesem flasten Witz der Sendungsgeschichte, kommen wir noch kurz zum Danke. Diesmal äh zweimal unbekannterweise,
ähm wenn ihr wollt, freue ich mich, wenn ihr euch äh bei mir meldet.
Oh. Das war's schon.
Ja, was soll ich da jetzt noch weiter ausführen? Weiß ich ja nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich freue mich ja immer, wenn wenn Dank zukommt.
Ich freue mich auch immer, wenn dann zukommt. Dann war's das jetzt erstmal. Das war äh das war die hundertfünfundneunzig und ähm fünf Mal.
Fünfmal müsst ihr noch sozusagen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik einschlafen.
Oder viermal und dann geht's los sozusagen.
Bestimmt viermal nur noch. Ui.
Vier Sendungen und dann dann geht's los.
Und wir haben jetzt äh keine Ruhe, ja? Wir haben jetzt hier Stress, ich wollte eigentlich Frieden haben. Jetzt haben wir hier diese Veranstaltung, Kongress Gala.
Tja, du bist es. Schlimm. Keine Atempause, Geschichte wird gemacht.
Gilt immer noch. So, bevor wir uns hier noch einen Kopf und Kragen reden, sagen wir einfach tschüss.
Ciao ciao.